COMMITTEE WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COPA NINETY
MERGES HERE TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GALLERIES IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVEPROCESS.
HOLIER COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE
CAPITOL AND THERE ARE NO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. WE WERE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PARTICIPATION
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AGAIN THE
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS IN MEMORY NEED BOTH
PHONE NUMBER AND THE ACCESS
CODE THE ACCESS CODE NUMBER IS
EIGHT ONE EIGHT. TWO EIGHT ONE
SEVEN THEY SAY THAT ONE MORE
TIME. EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO EIGHT
ONE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE FOR
THE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THERE MAY BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILLWAIT
IN A QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE
IT AND YOU'LL BE READY TO
pNOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY FEEDBACK OR DISTORTIONS.
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU CLEARLY AND WE
WANT TO. WE WANT TO DO THAT SO
WHEN YOU CALL IN MUTE THE LINE
YOU'RE WATCHING US ON TO THEM
WE CAN HEAR YOU WELL ALSO THANK
YOU AN APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
PATIENTS. OBVIOUSLY I MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICES. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED- THAT ALSO
GOES FOR FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE-
SUPPORTING CATEGORY ARE
OPPOSING CATEGORY WHEN IT'S THE
TIME TO JUST GIVE YOUR NAME.
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION IF YOU
CONTINUE TO SPEAK UNFORTUNATELY
WILL HAVE TO TERMINATE THE LINE
AT THAT POINT. IT'S ALSO A GOOD
TIME TO REMIND EVERYBODY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY THAT IS THAT
THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. TO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
YOUR TESTIFYING ON AND PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY FROM POLICY
COMMITTEE. OF EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE RE
RESPECTFUL OF PATIENTS SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. EVERYONE IS DOING THE
BEST THEY CAN UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND- PATIENTS
WOULD BE APPRECIATED. WE HAVE
SEVENTY SIX BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA AND ALL OF THEM ARE
SUSPENSE FIVE CANDIDATES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES HELLO
BUSY WITH THE GUY. RELEASE OF
THE MARY. THEY NOTIFIED THE
COMMITTED THEY DO NOT HAVE FIVE
OR CALM. FOR AN OF THE BILL ON
THE EDGE. SO THE REP. ON BE US
TODAY. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS THE BILL WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO
CHIEF CONSULTANT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
PER. I'M WORKING. HERE SENATOR
BATES SENATOR BRADFORD. CENTER
BRADFORD HERE SENATOR JONES.
SAWYER JONES HERE CENTER COME
LONGER HERE. ON LONGER HERE
CENTER LAYERED- LAYERED HERE
CENTER MY CAR. WE HAVE FIVE
NUMBERS BIRTH WE HAVE A CAR SO
WE'RE GONNA ON TO THE BILL OF
THE DO THEY CAN REGARDING THE
LANTERN HEARING. AND TECH CAN
AND CLEANING PROTOCOL SOBBING A
TIMELY ON WHEN TEST. EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED THREE MEN THE
WITH THERE'S ONLY BILL AN
ACTUAL. WITNESS TODAY SO THAT
PERSON WILL GET THREE MINUTES
FOR PRIMARY TESTIMONY ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MARC
TESTIFIED MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAMES
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. IF NECESSARY
WILL ALSO LIMIT THE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY TO TWELVE MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. AS A REMINDER ALL
WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY THE FISCAL IMPACTS
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM REPEATING
PRIOR POLICY COMMITTEE
ARGUMENTS. ALL RIGHT THE ME
TOOS WILL BE NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO OUR FIRST BILL
WHICH IS SENATOR MCGUIRE'S S.
B. TWELVE- IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE GOOD SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE THIS IS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PLANNING AND ZONING
WILDFIRES SO WILL OPEN UP FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWELVE. SO SUPPORT FOR
SB TWELVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME IN TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB TWELVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
ALREADY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. SEVEN MODERATE TURN YOUR
VOLUME UP BIT. SUCH SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWELVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. CAN
YOU HEAR ME BETTER LITTLE
BETTER A LITTLE MUFFLED BUT
IT'S A LITTLE LOUDER. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP OKAY SO NOW WE WILL
GO TO THE OPPOSITION ON S. B.
TWELVE. ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHON LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE SB TWELVE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE. MODERATORS OR
ANY OPPOSITION SB TWELVE.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP THIS TIME
AGAIN SHOW ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO. BUT STILL
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP OUR EYES
HAVING OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION- FOR
SB TWELVE AND HAVING NONE WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE OR COMMENTS. SO
WITHOUT OFF WITHOUT OPPOSITION
S. B. TWELVE IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON CASSIE EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER- THE SENATORS WAVE-
PRESENTATION THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL MOVE RIGHT INTO.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM AND THIS IS SB
EIGHTEEN ON GREEN ELECTRO.
ELECTRO LYTIC HYDROGEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM ARE YOU
MOVING OVER TO THE MICROPHONE
NO THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
PORTION TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHTEEN. THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY FIGHTERS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE. LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTEEN. PLEASE
PRESS OUT FOR BY ZERO TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT. ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
KILLING OUT ALL RIGHT WE'LL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYBODY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
WISHING OPPOSED SB EIGHTEENS
NON IS OR ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY
SEEING NONE SIR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE CUED UP TO OPPOSE SB.
EIGHTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW- TO.
EXPRESS YOUR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO. NOBODY
IS GIVING UP THE STRUCTURE ALL
RIGHT ONE LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION FOR SB EIGHTEEN
MODERATOR TO SKI ONE LAST CALL
OUT. SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
LEADERS. FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY EIGHT ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR WE ARE GETTING ANYBODY
QUEUING UP OUR RIGHTS NO ONE
SCREWED UP FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SB EIGHTEEN. SEEING
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB EIGHTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR SKINNER ON MATERNAL
CARE AND SERVICES- THIS IS OUR
NEXT ITEM IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAVE
PRESENTATION. WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY FIVE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PRESSURE
SUPPORT FOR A SIXTY FIVE MAIN.
ONE ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
LIKE TO STILL SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THE TIME
FOR SB SIXTY FIVE. WE DO HAVE
ONE CURRENTLY SHOWING SUPPORT
OF YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
THEY HAVE REMOVED THEMSELVES
FROM HERE. WITH NO ONE SHOWING
SUPPORT OUR WELL NOW ABA ABOUT
SIX FIVE. THERE'S NOBODY ON
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN OP AS SIX FIVE
NOBODY ROOM. TWENTY FIVE. WATER
OR ANYONE ON THE FOR LINE
WISHING OPPOSE AS SIX FIVE.
LADIES AND IF YOU LIKE HE'S ME
UP TO A SB SIX FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO ACT TIME. THE
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE SB SIXTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND I SHOW NO ONE SHOWING UP
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT ENOUGH OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY SB SIXTY FIVE AND
HAVING NONE AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIXTY
FIVE. FOR THE SUSPENSE LIVING
ON S. B. TWO FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER ON PROPERTY
TAXATION WELFARE EXEMPTION.
MUSEUMS THIS IS A TAX LEVY- IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE BEING
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION- AND
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. SEEING NONE TO
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NONE. IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT SB. TWO FIVE SEVEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER. MY APOLOGIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF WISH TO. AT
TWO BY SEVEN YOU MAY BE ONE
ZERO THIS TIME. WHAT THE TO
SHOW SUPPORT MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE FOR AT THE BY FIVE.
SPECIAL I SHOULD KNOW WHEN
CHILDREN. SHOW ARE THERE'S NO
IN THE- FOR SUPPORT WILL GO TO
A- THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE WISHING OPPOSE SB
TWO FIFTY SO. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THE. AND ONCE AGAIN TO OPPOSE
SB TWO FIVE SEVEN. ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND I SHOW NO ONE
SHOWING OPPOSITION EARLY OFFER
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION S. B. TWO FIFTY
SEVEN HAVING NONE AND THEN
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TWO FIVE SEVEN WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR ALSO BY SENATOR
SKINNER ON HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
PATIENTS STEERING- THIS IS THIS
IS. CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WHERE.
AND WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC.
IN SUPPORT OF A SPEECH FOR A ME.
FIVE TWO FOR- THERE'S NOBODY
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
THERE'S NO IN ROOM TO FORTY
MODERATOR ON THE LINE AND- OF
S. B. TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
SKINNER. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO CHAU SUPPORT FOR SB TWO FIVE
TWO FOUR THAT WAS WHAT THE
COULD AFTER FIVE TO. B. PRESS
ONE BUREAU AT THIS TIME. NEVER
MIND ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE TO FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I'M
JOINT REPORT. ALL RIGHT WILL
DROP OF A FIVE TWENTY- THEY'VE
NOBODY IN FORTY TWO- THREE-
THERE'S NOBODY. ON FORTY MODEL
ANY. ON THE PHONE LINE. FOR SB.
FIVE TWENTY FOUR. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW UP TO SB
FIVE TO FOUR MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN
THE SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AND I
HAVE A SHOW NO ONE SHOWING
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR HAVING GOTTEN NONE
AND SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB. FIVE TO FOUR WE'LL GO TO
SUSPEND. MOVING ON THIS TWENTY
EIGHT FIVE KERR BE A- ON ROLE
ROLL BROADWAY ENDED IN FOR.
VIDEO COPY REFORM ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIS IS A SUSPENSE
ITEM THE AUTHOR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL GO TO
OUR SUPPORT TESTIMONY WE DO
HAVE ONE OPPOSITION PRIMARY
WITNESS BUT WE'RE GONNA GO TO
SUPPORT FIRST. SEEING NO ONE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE WISHING TO
SUPPORT SB TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR CAVALIER WILL GO TO
ROOMS TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
FIGHTERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
SUPPORT FOR SB TWENTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TWO.
AND ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR SB TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO ACTIVE TIME WE
DO SO ONE PUTTING SUPPORT THERE
CURRENTLY WITHIN. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. HELLO ABOUT LINE ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO SHELVE THE
TO BE PRESS ONE TO ZERO FOR A-
TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WELCOME TO THE
LINE UP FIFTEEN FIFTEEN LINE IS
NOW OPEN. BERMAN THIS IS CHOICE
STERLING CHAIR THE RURAL CAUCUS
EXPRESSING SUPPORT. AND AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
SUPPORT TESTIMONY SB TWENTY
EIGHT. WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS ON THE COASTLINE CAROL
MCINTYRE WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION. WANTED TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. AS A REMINDER-
IS BACTERIAL HAVE THREE MINUTES
FOR YOUR WITNESS TESTIMONY-
MODERATOR TICKET. QUEUE UP- IS
BACK THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
KEVIN MCINTYRE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAITLYN. EQUIPMENT
SAID WE ARE. YOU AT ALL EIGHT
WHICH CAN TO BE UTILIZED THE
BIGELOW FOR. THAT WILL. RIGHT
OR VEHICLE SERVICE AND HOW. THE
FORCE THAT TO PLAY BROUGHT.
CLICKBAIT THAT BACK I THOUGHT
HE DID NOT EXTEND TO BROADBAND
BACCHANAL THE BILL WAS NOT
TECHNOLOGY. HE FELT THE SOUND.
THAT PLAYING BASKETBALL VIDEO
TECHNOLOGY FOR PURPOSES I AM
REQUIRING. ENTITY I. AND THE
BILL WHAT ACT AND THE UTILITY
COMMISSION. SEVEN OR REVOKE OUR
VIDEO FRANCHISE LIKE. CONSTAND
THERE SHOULD BE AT SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE A- SO THE HOLD UP
PERCENT CAN WE CLARA THE PHONE
SO WE ACTUALLY BETTER. SHE'S
USED. YEAH. THIS IS YOUR CELL
PHONE. YEAH. IF YOU COULD IF
YOU COULD SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO
YOUR PHONE THAT WOULD BE WHERE
WE'RE HAVING TROUBLE HEARING
YOU. SO TRY TO BE TRY TO GET
CLOSER TO WHATEVER MICROPHONE
TO YOUR PHONE AND TURN OFF ANY
OTHER DEVICE BECAUSE IT'S
PRETTY MUFFLED SO. YOU CAN
START OVER. OKAY EVERYBODY
SETTLE DOWN PLEASE. MS MCINTYRE
PLEASE START OVER YEAH OKAY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN PLANS OF
HAPPENED A COUPLE OF ON. THE
PROPOSAL IN OCTOBER THANK. SB
TWENTY OF TWENTY LEAD THE BILL
HAS I BEEN A MEMBER. WITH OR
THE PROVIDE BURKE ABOUT
IMPROVEMENTS SERVICE REQUIRES
COMPANY BROWN BALLOT BOX BUT
I'M WONDERING NOT. I HAVE BOTH
OF BALLOT. BIPHENYL LAW AND
FEDERAL LAW. WELCOME BACK. AT
BUT BOTH. OVER THE PROPOSAL AT
THE LUTHER ACT BUT REPUBLICAN
OF THE WITH THEM RIGHT THAT. A
LOT OF THE BILL. I'VE BEEN I'VE
BEEN I'VE BEEN. WELL. HI. THE
PUBLIC RECORD SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THE BALLOT. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH BOTH OF THE
TOP BUT BUT BUT NOT THAT. BUT
WILL THE POPE OF. THE LAST
DEVELOPMENT. OUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO OUR WITH.
IN OP OF SB TWENTY EIGHT AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM TO TWO
OF. NOVEMBER TWENTY FOUR
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD UP IN ON
THE PHONE LINE WHICH IS TO
OPPOSE S. TWENTY EIGHT. YES SIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SO OPPOSITION FOR SB
TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB TWENTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. AND I TOTALING SHOWING
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SP TWENTY EIGHT SINGLE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWENTY
EIGHT IS GOING TO GO TO
SUSPENSE. MISTER WHITE CAL SKI.
THREE SIX THREE SIXTY FIVE.
CONTINUE ON WITH US IN COVER
YOU LET'S CALL S. B. SIX FIVE
THE NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA THE-
ITEM IS A SUSPENSE CAN AND
MISCO EUROPE IS WE PRESS. LET'S
MOVE TO PUBLIC THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY SHE KNOWS HERE AND
FORTY TWO- THREE TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIXTY
EIGHTEEN WITNESS AND ROOM. FOR
ZERO TWO ZERO FOUR ZERO SOME
PLEASE PER. THE WITNESSES WHEN
FINDS OF S. THREE SIX FIVE.
LADIES AND IF YOU WERE OF THE%
FOR A THREE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. WHAT THE
INITIAL SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
SIXTY FIVE YOU MAY FOR ONE THE
ZERO AT TIME. AND DON'T KNOW
ONE CHOICE OKAY WITH THE SAME
PROCEDURE FOR OFFICE AS- NO
HERE IN ROOM. TWO THREE SIX
TESTIFY OP. OF US THREE TWO
FIVE NO WITNESSES AND ROOM-
TWENTY FORTY ENOUGH OF THREE
FIVE MORE PLEASE. PLEASE PROP.
WAITING TO FIVE. IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. SIXTY. CERTAINLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF AT THE
FOR AT THREE SIX FIVE MAY PRESS.
THEN AT THIS TIME. I WANT TO
SHOW OPPOSITION SB THREE SIXTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
THIS TIME. AND I SAID KNOWING
SHOWING UP AT VERY GOOD LET'S
GO THE PUBLIC HEARING BRING IT
TO MA'AM REQUEST FACING THE HAN
WITHOUT OF. IS THREE SIX FIVE
SOME OF THE SUSPENSE ACCOUNT.
NOW WE NEED TO S. B. THREE
NINETY FIVE BYTES COVER- HEALTH
HEALTH IN FOR. EDUCATOR ACT-
DECIDE IS ALSO A CANDIDATE FOR-
SUSPENSION IS WAY FOR. SO LET'S
SEE IF THERE ANYBODY HERE FORTY
OR THREE. ELECT TO TEST SOME OF
S. B. NINETY. THREE NINETY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BUT THE INITIAL SUPPORT
FOR SB THREE NINETY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I DON'T KNOW ONE SHOWING
SUPPORT VERY WELL LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS FOR TO HEAR
FROM OPPOSITION OTHER ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE NINETY FIVE C. NINE THIRD
NO WITNESSES AND IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN OPPOSITION TO THREE
NINETY FIVE SO. MODERATOR
PLEASE PROP WITNESSES WAS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE NINETY
FIVE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN A SHORT
POSITION FOR SB THREE NINETY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE SHOW KNOWING
NO ONE SHOWING SUPPORT TO THE
OPPOSITION FROM OKAY LET'S
BRING BACK MEMBERS. MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS ON SB THREE NINETY
FIVE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
NINETY FIVE IS MOVED TO
DISPENSE CALENDAR. SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT THIS FARMWORKERS DISASTER
RELIEF. PLANNING TASK FORCE
ALSO BY CENTER COVER EURO THIS
ITEM IS ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDID
IN HIS WAY PRESENTATION SO
LET'S PROCEED TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT I SEE NOBODY HERE. IN
ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE. WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT NOW DO I
SEE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM FIVE
TWENTY FORTY AND TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT
MODERATOR PLEASE PROD THE
WITNESSES. WILLIAMS HAS FIRED
EAGER TO AND S. B. FIVE EIGHT.
CERTAINLY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'RE EAGER TO UP SELL
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DON'T
THINK INITIAL SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE FIVE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
SO WE HAVE NO ONE SHOWING
SUPPORT VERY WILLFUL THE SAME
PROCEDURES FOR OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE I SEE NO WITNESSES
PRESENT ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE.
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT NOR DO I SEE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IN OPPOSITION OF FIVE FIVE
EIGHT MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE FIVE EIGHT. LADIES AND
DOMINUS OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE
FIVE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IT'S FOR AT FIVE EIGHT
MAY PRESS ONE AT THE AT THIS
TIME. SPECIAL KNOWLEDGE ON
OPPOSITION THANK YOU TWENTY OF
THE HAVE. ON FIVE FIVE BAY WITH
OBJECTION AS FIVE A JUST THIS
IS ACCOUNT MOVING THIS CENTER
NUMBER NEXXAR GENDER. OUR
AGENDA IS B. FORTY NINE INCOME
TO. CREDITS CALIFORNIA FOR FEES
TAX CREDIT- IT IS ALSO WAS
CANDID MISTER AMBER TO WE PRESS.
SLIDES ONE SIX ONE TO TEST TO
IS THERE A HERE. IN ROOM FORTY
TWO WITH. TIMES FIND OF SB FOR
NINE NINE I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM TO FORTY TO TEST ONCE FROM.
PLEASE PROPER WITNESS IS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FORTY NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN CHAU SUPPORT FOR SB
FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO SO ONE
SHOWING SUPPORT CURRENTLY WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
LINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MEMBERS KATELYN
OFFENSE AS THE COMPANY TRIES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM OF THIS NATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MODERATE NEARBY ANYBODY ONLINE
IN SUPPORT. NO ONE SHOWING
SUPPORT BUT I WILL PROMPT AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IS ALL
SUPPORT FOR SB FORTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THE TIME.
NO ONE SHOWING SUPPORTER VERY
GOOD LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS WE DO HEAR FROM ONE
OPPOSITION. I SEE NO WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM FIVE FORTY TWO OR
THREE IN OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY
NINE NOR DO I SEE WITNESSES. IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN A POSITION
OF. SB FORTY NINE MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT ANY ADDITIONAL.
WITNESSES WITH. ONE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VESTRY
FORTY NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THIS OPPOSITION FOR
SB FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT THE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN A SHORT POSITION FOR SB
FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I SHOW
NO ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION VERY
WELL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
I SEE NOBODY IN WASHINGTON HAVE
QUESTIONS ON THIS P. FORTY NINE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS REPORTED
LAST MONTH THE SUSPENSE
COUNTER. OUR NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA IS JUST BE ONE OH SIX
BUT CENTER MEMBER THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT INNOVATIVE.
PROGRAMS IT'S ALSO. A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND HE HAS WAY
PRESENTATION SOLICITED
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I SEEN. NO
ONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB ONE OH SIX NOR DO I SEE
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
DETAILS FIND SUPPORT OF ONE OF.
SB ONE OF SIX MODERATE IF YOU
PLEASE WITH PROP WITNESSES.
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE OH SIX. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB ONE OH SIX
PLEASE PRESS. ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WHAT THE INITIAL SUPPORT
FOR SB FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SPECIAL KNOWLEDGE ON SUPPORT
REGARDLESS FALL THE SAME
PROCESS FOR OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE AND-
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF S. B.
ONE OH SIX. I SEE NUMBERS NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB ONE OF SIX
A MODERATOR PLEASE WOULD YOU
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS GOING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB ONE
L. SIX. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR SB ONE OF SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. I
DON'T THINK INITIAL OPPOSITION
FOR SB ONE OF SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ESPECIALLY KNOWING NO ONE JOINT
OPPOSITION AT THE TIME FOR THIS
FOR THIS BILL. COULD DO ANY
MEMBERS ARE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BE ONE OF SIXTEEN THEM WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS B. ONE OH SIX. IS
MOVED TO SUSPENSE COUNTER
SENATOR STERN AT SEVEN BILLS
THAT WILL HERE NOW SB SIXTY
THREE IS THE FIRE PREVENTION
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PUBLIC
EDUCATION. IS ALSO A- SUSPENSE
CANDID MR STERN IS WAY
PRESENTATION SO LET'S MOVE TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE HERE ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. TO TEST FIND SOME
OF BREAST. SIXTY THREE SEEING
NONE DO WE HAVE WITNESSES WE
HAVE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SIX. SB SIXTY THREE
FOR MODERATE WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROP WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIXTY
THREE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IT'LL SUPPORT FOR SB SIXTY
THREE THEY PRESS ONE AT THE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SIXTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THE TIME. I DO
CURRENTLY HAVE TO IN CUBICLE
WITH OPERATORS ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN BIRTH PLAN THAT THE
BIRD ON BEHALF OF THE TREE CARE
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MAX. JUST ONE MOMENT ARE COMING
WITH AN OPERATOR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WENT TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF THOUSAND
OAKS IN SUPPORT. IS A LOT ALL
MODERATE THE- SUPPORT MEMBERS
ON THE PHONE. YES SIR AND THEY
HAVE BOTH HAVE SHOWN THEIR
SUPPORT OKAY LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS FOR OPPOSITION
OTHER ANY WITNESSES WHO
REPORTED KILL THREE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY THREE
SEEING NONE I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY THREE SO
MODERATE IF YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS GOING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY THREE.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
OPPOSITION FOR SB SIXTY THREE
MAY PRES ONE THEN ZERO
APPETITE. I WANT TO GET INTO A
POSITION FOR SB SIXTY THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AT THE TIME I SHOW NO ONE
SHOWING OPPOSITION. ACTIVITY IS
ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS AND SB SIXTY THREE
SEEING NON WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIXTY THREES MOTIVES IT'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX. BY CENTER STERN
WILDLIFE PROHIBITION OF.
COMPOSITION TRANSPORTATION
IMPORTATION OF WILD ANIMALS IS
ALSO IN. A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND HE IS WAY PRESENTATION SO
LET'S MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
HEARING IS ANYBODY HERE IN
ROOM. FORTY TWO OR THREE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX SEEING NONE. I SEE
NO WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY.
TWENTY FORTY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY SIX
A MODERATOR FOR PLEASE PROP
WITNESSES WAYNE. SAYS FIND
SUPPORT PRESS THREE THREE SEVEN
SIX. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IS A
FOR A THREE SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND THERE'S NO ONGOING SUPPORT-
pPOSITION OR THE WITNESSES HERE
AND FORTY TO THREE. IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SEVENTY
SIX I SEE NONE AT LOOK AT ROOM.
AT TWENTY FORTY I SEEN A
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN A
POSITION OF. SB. THREE SEVEN
SIX A MODERATOR FOR YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS. I WISH TO
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
THREE SEVENTY SIX. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN CHAU OPPOSITION FOR
SB THREE SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AS A REMINDER SHIP TO
SHORE OPPOSITION FOR SB THREE
SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
DO SHOW ONE PERSON SHOWING
OPPOSITION. GO AHEAD MY THIRTY
EIGHT YOU'RE LINING UP AND- HI
GET YOUR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MOTOR DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION SP THREE SEVENTY SIX.
YES I WILL NOT PROTECT YOU THAT
THEIR JUST A CALLING WITH AN
OPERATOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MONTH ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
ZOOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA AND WE ARE CLOSED SB
THREE SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATE
ANYBODY ELSE AND ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SEVENTY
SIX. NO ONE ELSE ONE OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE VERY GOOD LET'S
BRING BACK MANY QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS AND- SB THREE SEVENTY
SIX. WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
SEVEN SIX DECISIONS COUNTERED
CONNECTS ITEM ON THE AGENDA
SAYS BEING FOR TWENTY THREE BY
CENTER STERN ENERGY. RENEWABLE
AND ZERO CARBON RESOURCES THIS
ITEM IS ALSO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND HE IS WAY PRESENTATION SO
LET'S MOVE RIGHT TO THE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF THEIR
ANY WITNESSES HERE AND ROOM TO
FORTY TWO OR THREE TESTIFYING
SUPPORT SAYING NINE. I LOOK AT
ROOM AT TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF. S. B. R. THREE SO
MODERATE IF YOU PLEASE PROP
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FORTY THREE.
LADIES AND IS ALSO FOR AT FOUR
TO. MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR TO THREE
WITH A. PRESS ONE ZERO APPETITE.
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUAL WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FORTY THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PRESS BEFORE TWO THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR
SB FOUR TO THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AT THIS TIME. UNDERGONE
JOINT OPPOSITION- ARE A BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS ON. THIS BEFORE TWO
THREE WITHOUT OBJECTION AS
BEFORE THREESOMES TO SUSPENSE
COUNTER AND EXCITED MONDAY
GENESIS BEFORE FOUR NINE BY
STANDARD. STERN THIS ITEMS ALSO
SPENDS CANDID HIS WAVE
PRESENTATION SO LET'S MOVE ON
TO ANYBODY WHICH THIS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF S. B. FOUR FOUR
NINE I SEE NONE NOR DO I SEE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
ROOM. TWENTY FORTY TESTS FIND
SUPPORT FOR MODERATE WHEN WE
PROP WITNESSES WILLING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB FOUR
FOUR NINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR FOUR
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR FOUR NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NATIONAL ENJOYING
SUPPORT BRIGHAM'S FALL THE SAME
PROCESS FOR OPPOSITION IS
ANYBODY HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
FOUR FOUR NINE I SEE NONE. NO
DO I SEE WITH THIS IS IN ROOM.
TWENTY FOURTEEN OPPOSITION
SOMEONE READ WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS GOING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR FOUR NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR SB FOUR FOUR NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
BLACKISH OPPOSITION PRESS
BEFORE FOUR NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SACRAMENTO TO PROTEST BUT THAT
JUST QUEUED UP THE CALLING WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CARE NUMBER
BRAVO CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE OPPOSE THAT OR NOT THANK
YOU. NEXT FIND FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR TURN MEMBER
ECONOMICALLY THAT THE TO
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. MODERATOR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES OPPOSITION OF THIS
BEFORE. FOUR NINE. YES- LINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BALLERINA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION. FIFTY FOUR FOUR
NINE. NEXT. AND AT THE TIME I
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT THANK YOU SIR
VERY GOOD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANYBODY HAVE A
QUESTION ON THIS BEFORE FOUR
NINE WITHOUT OBJECTION JUST
BEFORE FOUR NINETY SUPPOSED TO
SUSPENSE COUNTER AND EXCITING
AS IT ON THE AGENDA VESTBY THIS
SB FIVE THREE THREE BY CENTER
STERN THIS ITEM IS ALSO SPENDS
CAN IN HIS WAY PRESENTATION
POLITICAL DIRECTLY TO WITNESSES
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WANT
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FIVE THREE THREE I SEE NOTHING
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
TESTS WERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE. THREE THREE I SEEN THAT
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
WITNESSES WHERE YOU TEST. BY
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THREE THREE.
LADIES AND IS OF THE FOR AT
FIVE THREE. PRESS ONE TO THAN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE
THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE PARK INVOLVED ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY THE SANTA
CLARITA THOUSAND OAKS AND SEAMY
VALLEY IN SUPPORT. NECKS. I
SHOULD KNOW WHEN ALSO IN
SUPPORT IT WAS FOR THE SAME
PROCEDURE FOR THE OPPOSITION OF
THE WITNESSES HERE ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE POINT TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
THREE C. NINE I SEE NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN OPPOSITION
TO FIVE THREE THREE SUB POTTERY
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S WAITING TO TESTIFY IN A
POSITION OF SB. FIVE THREE
THREE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THIS OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE
THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. I WANT TO GET
ISSUE OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE
THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT THE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SPECIAL KNOWLEDGE ON
OPPOSITION. BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I SEE NO HAN
FOR QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE THREE THREE
IS THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR IN
NEXT ITEM IS. ON THE AGENDA IS
SB FIVE FIVE ONE BY CENTER
STERN. ALSO IN CANDIDATE FOR-
SUSPENSE IN HIS WAY
PRESENTATION SO LET'S MOVE TO
THE- AT TESTIMONY. ANYBODY HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
WHICH IN TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE THREE I SEE
NINE IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY I
SEE NO ONE THEY'RE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF FIVE FIVE
THREE SOME MODERATOR. IF YOU'LL
PLEASE PROP ANY WITNESS PLEASE
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIVE ONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE
FIVE ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A
FEW THAT JUST. ACRYLIC
OPERATORS ONE OF. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY THE BELL
ROPE IN THOUSAND OAKS AND
SUPPORT. NEXT. NEXT QUARTER MY
NUMBER TWENTY NINE NINE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. BY
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI ARIEL LOPEZ FOUNDER
HAPPENED LOS ANGELES BUSINESS
COUNCIL AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB FIVE FIFTY ONE. NEXT. AT
NINE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. BY DAVID KING TYLER WITH
THE LOS ANGELES CLEANTECH
INCUBATOR RESPONSIBILITY AND
STRONG SUPPORT. MEXICANUS
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE FIVE ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. I SHOULD
KNOW WHEN I'M SHOWING SUPPORTER
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE THE
OPPOSITION FOLLOWING THE SAME
PROCEDURE THIS IS. SB FIVE FIVE
ONE CALIFORNIA LUXURY VEHICLE
AUTHORITY BY CENTER STERN I SEE
NO ONE HERE AND- PLEASE COME
FORWARD SIR TO THE MICROPHONE
RIGHT THERE AND- STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE FIVE ONE.
YES MY NAME'S PAUL MCGANN FROM
WIRE AMERICA I HAVE A POINT OF
ORDER FOR THE COMMITTEE WE WERE
BLOCKED FROM HAVING ANY
CONVERSATION AT ALL WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER EIGHT FULL
DAYS. AND WE HAD BEEN APPROVED
TO BE SPEAKERS AGAINST A BILL
THAT WAS SCHEDULED WE WERE
INFORMED FRIDAY MORNING THAT
THAT WOULD NOT BE HAPPENING WE
ASKED TO BE ACCOMMODATED WE GOT
NO RESPONSE BACK FROM ANYONE
AFTER VOICE MAIL AND EMAIL AND
EVERYTHING LSE YOU'VE CUT THE
PUBLIC OUT COMPLETELY. THERE
WAS NO OPPORTUNITY TO SCHEDULE
OPPOSITION AGAINST THESE BILLS
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE WOULD NOT
RESPOND TO DATE YOU HAVE ONE
SCHEDULE WALKING POSITION
SPEAKER ON ALL OF THESE BILLS
BECAUSE OF THAT. THIS IS A
FARCE OF A PROCESS YOU'RE
CUTTING OUT THE PUBLIC THIS IS
WRONG IT VIOLATES THE BAG THE
KEY TO ACT AND I'M SAYING TO
YOU THAT THIS WHOLE PROCEEDING
MAY NOT GO FORWARD IF YOU
CONTINUE TO CUT OUT THE PUBLIC
FROM BEING ABLE TO. COMMUNICATE
WITH THE COMMITTEE TO GET
OPPOSITION SPEAKER SPOTS THANK
YOU. COOLEY NOTED. ANY
EVERYBODY ELSE AND FROM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. WHICH IN A
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION OF. SB
FIVE FIVE ONE. ALL RIGHT. FIVE
MOVED TO FIVE ROOM FORTY TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION I
SEEN THEM THERE FOR SB FIVE
FIVE ONE MODERATE FEW PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUAL WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF. SB
FIVE FIVE ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THE TIME. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB FIVE
FIVE ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. I CHAU KNOWLEDGE
ON OPPOSITION ARTLESS MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WERE BACK ON
THE DAIS ANYBODY HAVE A
QUESTION ON SB FIVE FIVE PHONES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB FIVE FIVE
ONE IS MOVES SUSPENSE COUNTER.
NEXT UP IS A- SB SIX FIVE OH
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES BY
CENTER STERN. THIS ITEM IS A
SUSPENSE CAN ACT IN HIS WAY
PRESENTATION. LET'S MOVE TO
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWO FORTY TOOL
THREE CONTEST WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIX
FIVE OO I SEE NONE LET'S MOVE
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY EIGHT
SENIOR MEMBERS TESTIFYING
SUPPORT OF SB. SIX FIVE ALSO
MODERATE PLEASE PROP ANY
WITNESS WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIX FIVE OH.
LADIES GENTLEMEN SHOW SUPPORT
OF SB SIX FIVE OR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
WANT TO GET TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX FIVE OR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT A
LINE NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. IN THAT. KIND
OF. WHAT CONNECT. I NO UPSWING
SUPPORTER OKAY LET'S FALL THE
SAME PROCEDURES FOR ANY
OPPOSITION OTHER WITNESSES
PRESENT HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE- IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YES MY NAME IS PAUL MCGOVERN
WHY AMERICA THIS BILLS AMONG
ALL OF THE BILLS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN PROPERLY PROCESSED FOR TO
DAY AND HERE IS ANOTHER FACT
THAT WE NEED TO READ INTO THE
RECORD. WE HAVE A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGETS WITHIN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO ENABLE A
BUSINESS TO BE CONDUCTED EVEN
DURING COVERT NINETEEN TIMES
IT'S VERY SIMPLE TO UNDERSTAND
SOME PEOPLE WORK FROM HOME SOME
PEOPLE WORK IN THE OFFICE.
THAT'S PERFECTLY REASONABLE
HERE'S WHAT'S UNREASONABLE WHEN
YOU TRY TO CALL SOMEONE IT DIAL
JUST GOES DIRECTLY TO THEIR
PERSONAL CELL PHONE NUMBER
WHICH DOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH
SPACE TO TAKE VOICE MAIL
MESSAGES WELL I CALLED THE
COMMITTEE FROM MAY SIXTH EVERY
SINGLE DAY FORWARD. I GOT A
MESSAGE FROM SOMEONE CELL PHONE
SAYING WELL WE CAN'T TAKE ANY
MESSAGES THE MAILBOX IS FULL.
NO ONE DECIDED TO CLEAR THE
MESSAGES NO ONE DECIDED TO
ACTUALLY CHECK ANYTHING THERE
WAS NO OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
THIS COMMITTEE THROUGH THE
OFFICIAL NUMBER THAT'S ON THE
WEBSITE. THIS SYSTEM IS BROKEN
YOU CAN EASILY FIX THIS BY
PUTTING A BUSINESS LINE AT
EVERY PLACE OF BUSINESS WHERE
PEOPLE SET EVEN IF IT'S THEIR
HOME. AND YOU CAN SAY FOR SURE.
CONNECT YOU TO THEIR EXTENSION
AND THEN IT WILL FALL OVER TO
THE OTHER LINE AND THERE WILL
BE ENOUGH SPACE TO LEAVE A
VOICEMAIL MESSAGE. THAT IS THE
ONLY WAY TO GET SOMEONE'S
ATTENTION. NO ONE RESPONSE TO
YOU. NUMBER RESPONSE THE VOICE
MAILS I GOT MAYBE TOO. OKAY
THIS IS REALLY A BROKEN PROCESS
I HAVEN'T FULLY DOCUMENTED YOU
HAVE A LETTER FROM HARRY
LEHMANN ON MAY TENTH. SHOWING
YOU WHERE THIS IS VIOLATING
MANY RULES AND THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIX THIS BROKEN
PROCESS. FOR WHAT I CALL THE
SECOND HALF FOR THE FIRST TIME
FOR THIS FOOTBALL GAME. RIGHT
ALL THESE BILLS GO OVER DEAL
CHAMBER IN THE SECOND HALF. WE
NEED ACCESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OTHERS WOULD. MOTION
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION SB SIX
FIVE OO. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FIVE OH
SOME MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP ANY INDIVIDUALS
GOING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX FIVE OO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX BIBLE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FIVE OR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NO
ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION. VOTERS
ARE ANY MEMBERS. ON THE DAYS TO
HAVE A QUESTION OF REGARDING A
SB SIX FIVE OH SEEING THEM
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX FIVE
OF. THE SUSPENSE COUNTER.
CENTER BECKER HAS THREE BILLS
FIRST ONE UP IS SB SIXTY EIGHT-
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION THIS
ITEM IS A SPENT CAN GET MISTER
PACKERS WAY PRESENTATION. SO
LET'S MOVE RIGHT ON TO PUBLIC
AS MILLION SUPPORT HERE ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
TESTS FIND SUPPORT SB SIXTY
EIGHT SIXTY NINE I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM- TWENTY FORTY
TO SUPPORT AT. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY EIGHT SOME
MODERATE IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT ANY WITNESS POINTED OUT
JUST FINE SUPPORT SB. SIXTY
EIGHT BY BECKER. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
SIXTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
SIXTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. AND EXCELLING SHOWING
SUPPORT VERY GOOD LET'S FALL
THE SAME PROCESS DEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY EIGHT IS
THERE ANY WITNESSES PRESIDENT
ROOM FORTY TWO THREE. IT
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION OF SB
SIXTY EIGHT. PLEASE COME
FORWARD SIR PINE PAUL. YES THIS
FARMING HAVE WIRE AMERICA AGAIN
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO ALL
THE BILLS TODAY AND THE HERE'S
THE PROBLEM THAT WE SEE WITHIN
THESE COMMITTEES THESE
COMMITTEES TAKE YEAH AND VERY
SIGNIFICANT ANALYSIS LETTERS
THAT ARE EIGHT TO TEN PAGES
LONG THAT ACTUALLY SHOWED MUCH
SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE ON THE
RECORD WHY YOU DON'T WANT TO
APPROVE SOME OF THESE BILLS
THAT HAVE VERY SEVERE STE
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS YET THAT
DOESN'T MAKE IT INTO THE
ANALYSIS. RIGHT THERE'S NO WAY
THAT ANYONE CAN READ THAT STUFF
BECAUSE AUGUST SUMMARIZED INTO
A LITTLE PARAGRAPH THIS IS ALL.
IT'S KIND OF A CONCERN. WE ARE
NOT PUTTING CONCERNS INTO THE
RECORD WE ARE PUTTING
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE INTO THE
PUBLIC RECORD IT'S IN THE BILL
FILE WE UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT ONLY HAS
TO LOOK AT THE BILL FILE. AND
SO HERE WE ARE TRYING TO GET
GOOD INFORMATION INTO THE HANDS
OF SENATORS WHO NEED TO
DELIBERATE. AND MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS ON THESE BILLS YES
THE PUBLI IS CUT OUT ONCE
AGAIN. I THINK WE CAN FIX THIS
BY ZOOM YOU CAN DO THIS BY
MAKING THESE MEETINGS WITH
MEMBERS AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE BY
ZOOM. THIS IS HOW IT HAPPENS AT
ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. YOU CAN
ACTUALLY SAY HI WE'RE GONNA
HAVE ACCESS PLEASE INVITE TO
GET YOUR EXPERTS ON THE LINE
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BILL. THAT
WOULD BE A VERY GOOD SUGGESTION
FOR THE SECOND HALF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. PART BY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. R. I. SEE NO WITNESSES
IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY. TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SOME
WATER IF YOU PLEASE PROP
WITNESSES WAITING TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY EIGHT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS
OPPOSITION FOR SB SIXTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
OPPOSITION FOR SB SIXTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO.
THERE'S NOT MUCH OF AN
OPPOSITION VERY GOOD MEMBERS OF
THE- ON THE DAIS TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AND SB SIXTY EIGHT
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIXTIES
MOVED TO SUSPENSE CALENDAR.
NEXT UP IS S. B. FIVE NINE SIX
BY SENATOR PACKARD THE
GREENHOUSE GASES CEMENT AND
CONCRETE PRODUCTION THIS ITEM
IS A SUSPENSE CANDID HE'S WAVE.
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
SETS FIND. OF S. B. FIVE NINETY
SIX C. NINE I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN ROOM AT TWENTY FORTY
TESTIFIED SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE
NINE SIX A MODERATE PLEASE-PROMPT WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE
NINE SIX. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF SUPPORT FOR AT FIVE SIX MAY
PRESS ONE THEN. AT THE TIME. I
DON'T THINK INITIAL SUPPORT FOR
SB FIVE NINE SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
IT'S NOT SHOWING SUPPORT A VERY
GOOD LET'S FALL THE SAME
PROCESS. ON THE OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE. BOB PRESENT ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. THAT'S FINE
TOP POSITIONS MISTER. ALL OF.
THE AREA PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION BY
MEMBERS OF THE- THAT ON THE DAY
IS WILL STIPULATE TO THE
OBJECTIONS THAT YOU'VE MADE ON
AXIS WITH THE CELL PHONE AND
GETTING IN THE PHONE SYSTEM
ACCESS ON THE- THE- HAVING THE
ZOOMS AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE AND
ACCESS ON THE FINANCIAL OR
FISCAL. DISCLOSURES TO BE.
INCORPORATED INTO EVERY BILL
THAT WE HAVE ON THE CALENDAR
BECAUSE I GET THE SENSE THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO HAVE THE SAME
OBJECTIONS THEIR- ROUTINE NOT
TO PROTECT PARTICULAR MERITS OF
THE BILL IT'S A PROCESS. IF
THAT'S OKAY. CERTAINLY YOU MIKE
MY GOAL HERE IN MY COMMENTS IS
NOT TO DUPLICATE ANY SINGLE ONE
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
NEW IN GOOD SUBSTANTIAL
INFORMATION EVERY COMMENT THAT
I MAKE I'M NOT HERE TO WASTE
YOUR TIME. I'M HERE TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF ALL
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE FACING
IS THE PUBLIC HERE'S ANOTHER
ONE. WE HAVE SOME KIND OF CODED
NINETEEN QUOTE ON QUOTE
PROTOCOL THAT SEEMS TO BE
ENFORCED AS IF IT WERE LAW THIS
IS NOT LAW. ALL OF THESE
PROTOCOL THINGS HAVE BEEN
ACTUALLY DISMISSED BY MANY
STATES. RETURNEES JUST WALK UP
AND ACTUALLY SUE IT WAS A SAID
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN ILLINOIS
THAT SIT ON THIS ISSUE AND I
GOT ALL TAKEN CARE OF AND THERE
IS NO SUCH THING. SO THE BOTTOM
LINE HERE IS IF YOU JUST LOOK
AT THE EVIDENCE OF TOTAL DEATHS
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND FROM
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
TO THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY YOU
WILL SEE THAT THE NUMBERS ARE.
FOR ALL CAUSES TOTAL DEATHS
FROM ALL CAUSES ARE ALMOST
IDENTICAL. I TO WHAT YOU SAY
WHAT WE SAY TO EACH OTHER THAT
WE REALLY REALLY HAVE A
PANDEMIC WHERE THERE'S NO MORE
TOTAL DEATHS. IN TWENTY TWENTY
THAN THE ONES IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN AT SEVENTEEN.
CLEARLY THE EVIDENCE SAYS
OTHERWISE. CLEARLY THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR PROTOCOLS ARE
NOT THERE CLEARLY THIS IS NOT
STATE. LAW I THINK YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE TO OPEN UP. THIS PLACE AND
ALLOW US TO WALK AROUND AND
KNOCK ON DOORS AND DO THE KIND
OF LOBBYING THAT WE HAVE A
RIGHT. TO DO. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT. OTHERS TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS B. FIVE NINE
SIX THIS MOVED TO ROOM THOUGHT
TWENTY FORTY. I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE NOR HERE-
MODERATELY PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS NGUYEN TEST FINE
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINE SIX
AND CALL THEM. PLEASE
INTIMIDATION OPPOSITION FOR SB
FIVE NINE SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN A SHORT POSITION FOR SB
FIVE NINE SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND IT'S NOT SHOWING
OPPOSITION. NINE NO ANSWER OKAY
VERY GOOD LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS HAVING QUESTIONS
ON SB FIVE NINE SIXTEEN NO
HANDS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
NINE SIX IS MOVE THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR OUR NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA IS SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE BY
SENATOR BAKER ON SALES AND USE.
TAX LAWS ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
EXEMPTIONS THIS ITEM IS A
SUSPENSE CAN EASILY
PRESENTATION. SO LET'S GO RIGHT
TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONIES ARE
HERE ANYONE HERE. IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE EIGHTY
NINE. NOR DO I SEE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY
DETAILS FIND SUPPORT FROM
MODERATE PLEASE PROMPTLY THIS
IS. WHEN IT SAYS FIND SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE CALL THEM.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I
SHOW NO ONE SHOWING SUPPORT
VERY GOOD WAS FALLS IN PROCESS
FOR OPPOSITION OF THE WITNESSES
PRESENT IN ROOM FORTY TWO
THREE. TEST FIND OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE MISTER.
GALLAGHER BUT IF ALL THE
GOVERNMENT WHY AMERICA I
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE TO
HEAR EVEN MORE I HAVE IT'S ALL
ABOUT AFFECTS ALL THE BILLS SO
HERE'S ANOTHER ONE I TELL EVERY
SENATE DAILY FILE ON PAGE TWO
YOU HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT
PARAGRAPH THAT TALKS ABOUT
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS WE
ATTEMPTED TO GET ONE FOR THE
SENATE THIS TIME THAT YOU
REQUIRES BY THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN RULES FOR THE SENATE TO
ENTER INTO EIGHT INTERACTIVE
CONVERSATION AND DIALOGUE WITH
THE PERSON WHO MADE THE FILE. I
PUT IT IN ON THE SIXTEENTH OF
APRIL THERE WAS NO INTERACTIVE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO SUGGESTION WHATSOEVER FROM
THE SENATE. AND THAT JUST
DISQUALIFIES A BY FEDERAL LAW.
I AM SUGGESTING TO YOU THAT YOU
YOU INSTRUCT ALL AMERICAN
CONTRAIRE US AND HER PEOPLE TO
FOLLOW THE FEDERAL LAW WITH
RESPECT TO PROCESSING EIGHTY
EIGHT REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS
WE WILL NEED ONE FOR THE SECOND
HALF TO HAVE ACCESS. TO THE
SENATORS IN ORDER TO BE
PROPERLY DELIBERATE ON THESE
BILLS THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
OTHERS SEEING THEM OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE MONTHS OF TWENTY
FORTY AS YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS
THEIR MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE. CALL ANY WITNESSES
WAITING TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU OPPOSITION FOR
SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. WE
DO HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS CAROLINE SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM THE STATION IS ACTUALLY
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB SEVEN
SEVEN ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. I SAW NO ONE
ELSE ON OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN ONE THING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVEN SEVEN ONE THE MOVE TO
SUSPENSE FOR MOVING ON TO
SENATOR ALLEN SP EIGHTY THREE
SEA LEVEL RISE REVOLVING LOAN
PROGRAM. THIS ITEM IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SENATE ALLEN
IS WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL
MOVE TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHTY THREE ON SEA LEVEL
RISE. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE IN SUPPORT. NUMBER
ZERO TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
HEARING ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY THREE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SUPPORT
FOR SB EIGHTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I DON'T THINK INITIAL
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHTY THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME
THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING SUPPORT
THERE. ARE I WILL NOW MOVES
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SENATOR
ALAN. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY ONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB EIGHTY THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN JUST SO OPPOSITION
FOR SB EIGHTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THE TIME.
I WANT TO GET INTO A POSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO FOR SB
EIGHTY THREE. AND I DON'T WANT
JOINT OPPOSITION I HAVE AN
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SPORT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHTY
THREE AND HAVING MANAGING THE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHTY
THREE. OF OUR SUSPENSE MOVING
ON ITS BEFORE THREE THREE
SENATOR ALAN CALIFORNIA COASTAL
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
ENFORCEMENT PENALTIES. THIS IS
A SUBSISTENCE CANDIDATE CENTER
ALLEN IS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
GO RIGHT TO TAX MONEY'S SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
THREE THREE TWO SEVEN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOUR THREE THREE THREE MONEY ON
THE PHONE INE. IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR THREE THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
FORTY THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO AT THE TIME.
DOMESTIC INITIAL SUPPORT FOR SB
FORTY THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND IT'S NOTSHOWING SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT REMOVED OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR THREE THREE. SO MANY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB FOUR THREE
THREE THE SEMINARY TWENTY
FORTIES ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED US BEFORE THREE
THREE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THIS OPPOSITION FOR SB FORTY
THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB FOUR
THREE THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND I SHOW NO ONE SHOWING
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF US
BEFORE THREE THREE SINGLE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS BEFORE
THREE THREE WILL GO TO SISENSE
MOVING ON SB FIVE SIXTY THREE
BY CENTER AROUND. ON SECOND
HAND SECOND NEIGHBORHOOD INFILL
FINANCING TRANSIT IMPROVEMENT
ACT- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE CENTER HOURS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. OTHERS NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE HEARING
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FIVE SIXTY THREE. WE NEED
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB FIVE SIX THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE TO HAVE QUEUED UP ONE OF
THE OPERATOR ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY FIFTY ONE
AFTER WITH SOUTH WHICH YOU.
JUST A MOMENT HERE FOR THE NEXT
LINE. ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MODERATOR
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE JOURNAL
SPECTER BEHALF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SUPPORT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE SIX THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE ON THE
COURT. ALL RIGHT WILL NOT GO IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SIXTY
THREE. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE OPPOSERS
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB FIVE SIXTY THREE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE SIX
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I WANT TO GET INTO A
POSITION FOR SB FIVE SIX THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSPECTIVE CALLING WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
ONE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ONE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARX AND FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE POLICY THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED ON THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY SO NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. I HAVING TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE SIXTY THREE ANSWERING OF
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB FIVE
SIXTY THREE WITH A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB SIX ELEVEN BY
SENATOR ALLEN ON. INCOME TAX
CREDITS FOR THE MOTION PICTURE.
INDUSTRY THIS IS A TAX LEVY- WE
WILL MOVE TO- COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX ELEVEN BY
SENATOR ALAN. WHERE MEMBERS
CHRIS MCKAY LEE ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEE NO ONE ELSE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE WILL MOVE TO
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE IN SUPPORT I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
SUPPORT. BINARY PLEASE QUEUE UP
THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT FOR
SB SIX ELEVEN BY SENATOR ALAN.
ADEQUATE YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
ELEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THE
BUREAU AT THE TIME. WE HAVE TO
IN Q. CURRENTLY LINE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BECAME CHAIRMAN. OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL SUPPORT. BLIND
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWENTY MEDICARE MEMBERS JAMES
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AT THE TIME
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T THINK YOU
ARE I REMOVED OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX ELEVEN BY SENATOR ALAN
THERE'S NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE OPPOSED. SOMEBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSE BATTERIES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SB SIX ELEVEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
OPPOSITION FOR SB SIX ELEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THE TIME. WANT TO GET A TO
OPPOSITION PRACTICALLY LEVIN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING UP
INITIATIVE CONTINUES HER. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX ELEVEN-
AND WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SIX ELEVEN. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB ONE TEN
BY SENATOR WIENER ON SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES- THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. MISTER
WINNER HAS WAY PRESENTATION- WE
WILL GO T TAX MONEY TO SUPPORT
A COMPANY FORTY TWO OH THREE IN
SUPPORT. OF A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IN OPPOSITION EXPERIENCE
SUPPORT AND A MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB ONE TEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN CHAU SUPPORT FOR SB
ONE TEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I DON'T THINK
INITIAL SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME FOR SB
ONE CAT. YOU HAVE ONE PERSON
SHOWING SUPPORT THE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE ISRAELIS
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
OFFICE OF MARYLAND AND GREED.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. AND AT THE TIME I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE SHOWING.
PARK ARE ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION OF SB ONE
TEN- SIR THIS IS THE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION THIS
IS NOT THE SPEECH TIME SO FOR
YOU. ARE WILLING TO GIVE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION I'LL HAVE YOU COME
FORWARD IF YOU GO BEYOND THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TURN OFF THE
MICROPHONE OKAY. THERE IS NO
POINT OF ORDER NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION THANK
YOU YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. ALL THE
GAVEL WHY AMERICA AYE OPPOSE
ALL OF THESE BILS FOR DUE
PROCESS VIOLATIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
OPPOSED SB ONE TEN. THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY TWENTY
ONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB ONE TEN. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ISSUE OPPOSITION FOR
SB ONE TEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DON'T
THINK INITIAL OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO FOUR SB ONE
TEN. AND I DON'T KNOW ONCE
OPPOSITION HERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HAVE BEEN TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION ON SB ONE TENSING UP
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ONE TEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. LIVING ON
S. C. TWO SIXTY FIVE SENATOR
WIENER ON CLIMATE CORPORATE
ACCOUNTABILITY- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL GO TO
TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT. IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE IN SUPPORT WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- THERE'S NOBODY
THERE MODERATE IF YOU CAN QUEUE
UP THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO SIXTY. EMBODY THE
TELEMEDICINE SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I WANT TO
GET TO SHOW SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO FOR SB. TWO
SIXTY. I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
EXPORTERS TESTIMONY AGAIN SIR I
WILL RECOGNIZE YOU AGAIN IS
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR. ALL THE GOVERNMENT WIRE
AMERICA WHAT WE SEE IS AGES BY
A SCORCHING OF THE PUBLIC'S
VOICE EVEN IN THIS HEARING
WHERE ARE TWO MINUTES ARE BEING
STOLEN FROM US RIGHT NOW BY THE
CHAIR AND THAT ALSO VIOLATES
DUE PROCESS ALL IN ALL OF THESE
BILLS. WE RECOGNIZE THAT AS AN
OPTION HI MY OPPOSITION IS
STRONG THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED S. B. TWO SIXTY SEEING
NONE. WE WILL MOVE TO THE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY IN
OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THERE ANYONE ELSE OPPOSED SB.
TWO SIXTY. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF OPPOSITION FOR SB
TWO SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE TO
IN Q. ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JUST
HIGHER FROM THE TALK ABOUT A
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BUILT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AT ONE MOMENT PLEASE FIND
EXPLAINED A COUPLE WITH AN
OPERATOR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE PLAN FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT GAME OKAY
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION RESPECT
OPPOSITION. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE PARTICULAR NOT ALLOWED TO
BE AVAILABLE JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ONE FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. SEAN MONAHAN
CALIFORNIA DEPEND A PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE
I GOT BUT IT SHOULD AT THE
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
SIXTY SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO SIXTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
SB SIX SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
WIENER ON RESIDENTIAL SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEMS. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL MOVE
INTO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SEVENTEEN ON RESIDENTIAL
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS SEE NO ONE
IN SUPPORT WILL MOVE TO TWENTY
FORTY. THERE'S NO ONE THERE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE OF
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVENTEEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT
FOR SB SIX SEVENTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON IN
CUBA LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
WILLIAM BROUGH BURKE WITH THE
AT OP. WILLIAM AFTER BURKE FROM
MY HUSBAND AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING CLIENTS. HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY IN COURT AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO PLAN AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OFTEN AND
BURKE. AT THE CUT BANK THERE
THANK YOU. NEVER MIND RELATED
TO TELEMEDICINE SUPPORT FOR SB
SIX SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE ON SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SEVENTEEN.
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
BUT WE DO HAVE A PERSON IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO WOULD IKE TO
SPEAK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AGAIN
YOUR NAME. COMMON FOR YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
ON SB SIX SEVENTEEN. WHAT IS
BOMBING EVAN WIRE AMERICA AND
THE MASONS MANUAL. PROCEDURE IT
IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT THIS
BODY FOLLOW THE PRINCIPLES AND
IF YOU LOOK ALONG WITH A
CALIFORNIA COMES AS A THIS IS A
WHEN THEY DIED THIS IS A-
PROBLEM WITH ALL THE BILLS.
THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE
PLEASE CONFINE YOUR TESTIMONY
TO YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE WILL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSED
SB SIX SEVENTEEN THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SIX SEVENTEEN AGAIN.
ITS NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB SIX
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO. I WANT TO GET INTO A
POSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THIS TIME WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
IN THE QUEUE LINE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
POP IN THE OFFICE OF THE UP THE
CITIES OF PORN THOUSAND OAKS
AND LYFT AND MAKE WORK AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. NEVER
MIND IF ELECTED OPPOSITION FOR
SB SIX SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE WOULD HAPPEN. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
SB SIX SEVENTEEN. AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX
SEVENTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WILL MOVE ON TO S. B. TWO
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR DOLLY- I
WAS HOPING YOU WOULD WAY
PRESENTATION BUT YOU ARE. BENT
ON MAKING YOUR PRESENTATION
HONESTY TO SEVENTEEN SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT ON
SB TWO SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT SCHOOLS
SEXUAL EDUCATION MATERIALS BE
POSTED ONLINE FOR PARENTS
REVIEW TO REVIEW THEM GIVEN THE
CURRENT DISTANCE LEARNING
EDUCATION SYSTEM EVEN WITH THE
RECENT PLAN FOR SCHOOL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
OPENS. PARENTS OFTENTIMES
CANNOT PHYSICALLY VISIT THE
SCHOOLS ACQUIRE MATERIALS THAT
WILL BE TAUGHT TO THEIR
CHILDREN SECTION FIVE ONE THREE
NINE EIGHT B. NUMBER ONE OF THE
CATS CALIFORNIA HEALTHY. YOUTH
ACT REQUIRES THAT PARENTS BE
NOTIFIED. THE MATERIALS IS
AVAILABLE FOR INSPECTION THE
SHIFT TO THE INTERNET BASED
DISTANCE LEARNING HAS PROVIDED
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR SCHOOLS. TO
GET PARENTS MORE ENGAGING OR
THEIR CHILD'S EDUCATION THIS
BILL HELPS FOR THAT GOAL. ALL
WE ARE DOING HERE IS TO ENSURE
THAT PARENTS CAN BE ENGAGED AT
THE LEVEL THEY CHOOSE IN THEIR
CHILD'S EDUCATION THE COST FOR
THIS BILLS ARE MINOR THE COSTAS
BILL AS MINOR. AS NOTED THE
ALICE'S AND RIGHT NOW IS THE
BEST TIME FOR US TO PURSUE
THIS. GIVEN THE SURPLUS OF
FUNDS AVAILABLE TO SCHOOLS
THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND THS
BILL IS GOING TO SPENT AND I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT IT.
WHEN IT BECOMES FROM THE
SUBSISTENCE FILED COMMITTEE
HEARING THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SEVENTEEN THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY SECTION ME. FORTY
TWO OH THREE. THERE'S NO MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTEEN.
AFTER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IT
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO SEVENTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO APPETITE.
THE COMPANY CURRENTLY HAVE TO
IN Q. ONE TO THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE DALLAS WITH.
HI GOOD MORNING AND TRANSLATORS.
BONTA BURKE ON BEHALF OF A
REPROACH CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WE HONOR
ON SUPPORT RIGHT NOW. AND WHAT
THE CAN LEAD TO MEDICAL SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO SEVENTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME ONE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS A MICHAEL MCCABE I'M A
RESIDENT OF THAT TO THE BEST.
AND I SUPPORT. S. B. TWO
SEVENTEEN. WE DO HAVE OUR
POTENTIAL IN SUPPORT OF YOU
JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE FIVE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS TONY ROMA'S DALLAS
THE CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTY.
AFTER A MINOR LEAGUE
TELEMEDICINE SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE ON
THE PORT ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NEVER OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
SEVENTEEN- SIR IF YOU CAN COME
UP AND GIVE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION-
WE HAVE STIPULATED THAT MOST OF
YOUR TESTIMONY PRIOR TO MY
COMING BACK I SAW WATCHED WAS.
PROCEDURAL ISSUES NOT ON THE
MERITS OR THE OPPOSITION OF A
BILL OF THE FISCAL IMPACTS TO
THE BILL I HAVE SPECIFIC ACTS
OR THIS BILL ALL RIGHT PLEASE
LOG OUT NAY NO YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
I HAVE NO PRIMARY OPPOSITION
SPEAKER SCHEDULE WHY CAN I NOT
BE ONE OF THE- LOVING TO. YOUR
POINT OF ORDER Y. KENTUCKY ONE
SIR YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION. YOU HAD MORE
TIME SPEAKING TODAY THAN ANY
OTHER PERSON THANK YOU BECAUSE
I SHOWED UP THANK GOD. THANK
YOU YOUR CALL MAY DIVE IN WIRE
AMERICA YOU MUST FOLLOW
EVERYTHING TO GET US ON A
SPEAKER IS THAT A SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THAT IS AN OPPOSED
BECAUSE YOU DON'T MAKE YOU WANT
TO LISTEN TO THE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED S. B. TWO SEVENTEEN.
SEEING. NINE WILL MOVE ON TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY'S
WILL GO THE PHONE. THIRTY ONE
OPPOSE THIS TWO SAID. WE HAD
ONE ALREADY ANYONE ELSE
SUPPOSED S. B. TWO SEVENTY. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB TWO SEVENTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN
Q. ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIVE OF THEM ARE OPEN
WITH. AN APPOINTMENT CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION THANK. FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THAT'S WHY FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
PROCEDURAL MORNING CHEN MEMBERS
HI THIS IS CARLOS MACHADO WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB TWO SEVENTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND YOU'RE A
LOT OF TIME. THERE'S NO ONE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO SEVENTEEN MISTER
DAHLE YOU'RE WAVING YOUR
CLOTHES- SAYING NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES THAT
OBJECTION SB THREE SEVENTEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
SB TWO TWO TWO BY SENATOR DODD
ON WATER RATE ASSISTANCE THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SENATOR
DODD IS WAY PRESENTATION- AND
WE WILL GO TO SUPPORT TESTIMONY
OF S. B. TO ANYONE HERE THERE'S
NOBODY EVER FORTY TWO OF THREE
THIS COMPANY ROOM. TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PEASE QUEUE
OF ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO TWO AND
AGAIN IT'S NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
TWO TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB TWO TWO TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. LET NO
ONE SHOWING SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION S.
B. TWO TWO TWO. SIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COME TO GIVE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. BINANCE PAUL MCGAVIN
FROM WIRE AMERICA AND WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS ACTION CAN
HAVE OUR VOICES HEARD THANK YOU
CAN YOU INDULGE US THANK YOU
WHAT IS YOUR POSITION YOUR AND
OPPOSED SB I'M TEACHING
EVERYONE OF THE THANK YOUS THAT
ARE BREAKING THE LAW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
TWO TWO. THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM. THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
OTHER ROOM MODERATOR'S ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED S. B.
TWO TWO TWO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IT'S OPPOSITION FOR
SB TWO TWO TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO APPETITE. AND
WHAT THE INITIAL OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE DO
HAVE ONE POTENTIAL OPPOSITION
MY TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE POP
IN THE OFFICE OF THE UP THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY WATER LITIGATION
WITH THE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION THANK YOU. AND I SHOW
NO ONE ELSE SHOWING OPPOSITION-
ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO TWO
TWO. A SINGLE QUESTION FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWO TWO TWO A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON
SB TWO TO THREE BY SENATOR DODD
ON DISCONTINUATION OF
PRESIDENTIAL WATER SERVICES.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
AND WE WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
IN SUPPORT OF TWO TWO THREE.
SEVEN IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT OF TWO TO THREE.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
TO THREE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF SUPPORT FOR SB TWO TO THREE
MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I WHAT THE CONDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO TO THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THERE'S
NO ONGOING SUPPORT. THERE'S NO
SUPPORT PRESS B. TO OR NO ONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO TO THREE WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION- ANYONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING
TO OPPOSE SB TWO TO THREE SIR
PLEASE COME UP STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. ON SB TWO TO THREE.
YES MY POSITION IS BY MY PAUL
THE GOVERNOR AMERICA POSITION
IS THAT THESE BILLS NEED TO GO
THROUGH A PROPER PROCESS AND SO
THEY'RE NINETY REASON FOR MY
OPPOSITION. NINETY SEVEN
CONSIDER BEING THANK YOU EVERY
DAY HERE THANK YOU WILL MAKE
ROOM FOR OTHER FOLKS IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE WISHING TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS FOR ANYONE. ON
THE PHONE LINES OPPOSED SB TWO
TO THREE. AFTER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THIS OP FOR SB TWO
THREE MAY PRESS ONE AT AT BEST.
SILADZIC INITIAL OPPOSITION
PRESS BE TWO TO THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO WE DO HAVE
ONE PERSON TO DEATH. BY TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE POP IN THE OFFICE
FROM THE UP THE THING YOU'RE A
VALUE WATER. XIN IS OPPOSED AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT- AT AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU. AND
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE ON OPPOSITION THERE. ARE
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO TO THREE
SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWO TO THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. LEVINE S. B. TWO
THREE THREE TWO FIVE SENATOR
DODD ON CIVIL LIABILITY
PRESCRIBED BURNING OPERATIONS
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
WE WILL GO TO SUPPORT
POSITIONS. NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. MR CHARMERS MY
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMBOLDT AND MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANY'S IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER KELLY WE WILL GO NO ONE
ELSE IN THIS ROOM WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY NO IS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THREE THREE TWO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'LL
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE THREE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE THREE TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. I
SHOW NO ONE SHOWING SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
TWO ON CIVIL LIABILITY AND
PRESCRIBED BURNS PLEASE COME UP
AND SHARE YOUR POSITION ON
PRESCRIBED BURNS. WELL THE GUY
WHO ARE MARIKA MY POSITION
SENATOR DODD HE HAD A BIG YOU
KNOW PLEASE SIR SIR SIR WE DO
NOT REFERENCE. SIR WE DO NOT
REFERENCE SIR. WE DO NOT
REFERENCE MEMBERS IF YOU.
PLEASE STICK TO NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
KNOW ANYONE AROUND TWENTY FORTY
NOW SIR I WILL SAY IF YOU IF
YOU DO WELL AFTER MEMBERS AND
WE WILL WE WILL NOT EVEN HAVE
YOU COME UP SO PLEASE KEEP YOUR
NAME T. PLEASE KEEP YOUR
POSITION TO YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
LIKE EVERY LIKE EVERYONE ELSE.
THANK YOU. LIKE EVERYONE ELSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE. FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE THREE
TWO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS
OPPOSITION FOR SB THREE THREE
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I WANT TO GET
INTO A POSITION FOR SB THREE
THREE TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO. AND IT'S NOT SHOWING UP
THE PAGE AND- THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE LINE
HAVING HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE TO. ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THREE THREE TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ONTO SAP S. B.
TWO FIVE FIVE FIVE ME.
PORTANTINO HEALTH INSURANCE
EMPLOYER ASSOCIATIONS LARGE
GROUP HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS-
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
I'VE WAVE PRESENTATION WILL GO
TO. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S ONLY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. FIGHTERS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FIVE FIVE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO FIVE FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN SHOWS SUPPORT
FOR S. B. TWO FIVE FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND I HAVE NO
ENJOYING SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE NO SUPPORT OF SB TWO FIVE
FIVE WE WILL NOW MOVE TOP
POSITION OF S. B. TWO FIVE FIVE
WE'RE WE'RE TREATING EVERYONE
EQUALLY AND PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERYONE TO
STATE THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
SIR IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
UP. AND SHARE YOUR OPPOSITION
YEAH I'M FROM WIRE AMERICA AND
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION SPEAKERS
SCHEDULED YET NONE IS ALLOWED
AND I DON'T QUITE NINETY VERY
MUCH SIR I AM SAYING IS THAT WE
HAVE THE BADLY THANK YOU WRITE
YOUR- WORTHWHILE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR SHOULD BE IN
OPPOSITION S. B. TWO FIVE FIVE.
BUT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED S. B. TWO
FIVE FIVE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU OPPOSITION FOR SB TWO
FIVE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN A SHORT POSITION FOR SB
TWO FIVE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FIVE
FIVE SHE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWO FIVE FIVE. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE REMOVING ON SB THREE
EIGHTY ONE BY PORTANTINO A
SURPLUS RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY.
PARTISAN PROCEDURES IN THE CITY
SOUTH PASADENA THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE I'VE WAY
PRESENTATION- HI IT'S A
SUSPENSE KENNEDY I'VE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WE WILL GO TO
SUPPORT. FOR SB THREE EIGHTY
ONE. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THAT HAVE ANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. I WANT TO
GET IT OFF THE POINT FOR SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. AND IT'S NOT
SHOWING SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE. THERE IS NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY HERE AT THE MICROPHONE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SIR ANYONE ON NO IN THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE EIGHTY ONE.
EMBODY DIGITAL INITIAL
OPPOSITION FOR SB THREE EIGHTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN A SHORT POSITION FOR
SB THREE EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING
OPPOSITION. NO OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE- AND NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
EIGHTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AS BEFORE EIGHTY FIVE BY
PORTANTINO INCOME TAX TAX
CREDITS CERTIFIED SHE OF
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. WE WILL
GO TO SUPPORT THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES MR MCHALE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION YES MISTER CHAIR
IN SUPPORT OF YOUR MEASURE ON
BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THANK YOU MISTER
AND YOUR NAME IS. CHRIS MY
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY ONE
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. IN SPORT OF THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT- FOUR EIGHT FIVE SKEWS
ME- THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR EIGHT FIVE MONTEREY IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR EIGHT FIVE.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IS
ALSO PART FOR SB FORTY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE THREE IN Q. ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NOT GEORGIA
NUMBERS BETWEEN JANICE NOT SURE
ON BEHALF OF GOVERNMENT.
SPONSORING AND SUPPORTING THANK
YOU. ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. DISNEYLAND SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MISTER MEMBERS JAMES CORRECT OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LABORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB FORTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
SHOWING SUPPORT ALL RIGHT WILL
NOW MOVE ON OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE AND WILL GO TO
THIS ROOM SIR PLEASE COME UP
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
ON SB FOUR EIGHT FIVE REMEMBER
THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE
PLEASE STATE OUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION
YES MY NAME'SPAUL MCGANN FROM
WIRE AMERICA AND MY POSITION IS
SUPPORTED BACK WE CAME BACK TO
SAYS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
THEIR NEEDS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR PLEASE GET THE
MICROPHONE OFF. I DON'T SEE IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHARE YOUR PASSION AND THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
WANTING TO OPPOSE SB FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE STE YEAH COME ON UP
SIR YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION. MY NAME IS
ALEX FROM FROM SAFE TECHNOLOGY
FOR SANTA ROSA AND I JUST WANT
TO STAND WITH MR THANK YOU. NOT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR. THIS IS A FULL. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM KNOW
WE SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
ANYONE A ROOM TWENTY FORTY KNOW
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE
THIS BEFORE EIGHTY FIVE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I WANT TO GET
INTO OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. ARE I HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AND
SB FORTY FIVE AND SEEING NONE
N. X. AMAZING NO QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FORTY FIVE AGO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING HONESTY SIX TWELVE BY
PORTANTINO AN ELECTRICAL CORD
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS ANOTHER
LOAD SERVICE ENTITIES
ALLOCATION OF LEGACY RESOURCES-
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE I
PLAY PRESENTATION I'VE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL GO TO
SUPPORT. TESTIMONY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
COMING IN THE MICROPHONE IS A
MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
TWELVE. LADIES GENTLEMEN SILVA
FOR SB SIX ONE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. NEXT
TUESDAY. WHAT THE CONDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX ONE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO WE DO
HAVE TO IN Q. ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
POP IN THE OFFICE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY THE CAMARILLO THOUSAND
OAKS CARBON. YOUR NUMBER
BATTLING. BUT THE COUNTY IS
THAT CONTRA COSTA BACK PROGRAM
YEAH A LOT OUR- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN I FROM ADDITIONAL FOR
A SIX TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO OF TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE SINCE YOU STARTED YOUR
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN A
SUPPORT TESTIMONY AND NOW WE'LL
GO TO OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE
OPPOSED SB SIX TWELVE. ON
LEGACY RESOURCES SIR PLEASE
COME UP AND STATE YOUR NAME.
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON SB SIX TWELVE THAT
IS THE BILL BEFORE US. I DO
UNDERSTAND SIR I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
TO LISTEN TO US ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION MIGHT GIVE YOU MY
NAME SIR. MY NAME IS PAUL KEVIN
MY ORGANIZATION IS WIRE AMERICA
WE REPRESENT THANK YOU FOR
MILLION ELECTROMAGNETIC
SENSITIVE CALIFORNIANS THANK
YOU WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF
EUROPEAN L'ORGANISME OPPOSITION
FIVE BY SIX AND THREE SEVEN
EIGHT IS YOUR POSITION
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THAT DOES
NOT HAVE A THANK PUBLIC AS A
PRIMER ON- WHICH IS AVAILABLE
TODAY SIR. THANK YOU SIR I'M
GONNA FOR THE NEXT BILLS.
SOMEBODY GIVE YOU ONE MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION UNFORTUNATELY IF YOU
DEVIATE FROM THAT AGAIN. I AM
GOING TO HAVE TO STOP HAVING
YOU COME UP SO I JUST THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SIR ANYONE THERE KNOW WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX TWELVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THIS OPPOSITION FOR
SB SIX TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN THE SHOP ATTENTION FOR SB
SIX ONE TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I DON'T
JOINT OPPOSITION THERE. ARE AYE
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX TWELVE. WITH THAT NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX TWELVE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WE WILL
MOVE ON TO DOCTOR PANS S. B.
TWO FIVE SIX ON CALIFORNIA
ADVANCING INNOVATIVE MEDIC CAL-
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE DR
PANDA'S WAY PRESENTATION- WE
WILL GO TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IF SUPPORTERS OF ANY ROOM
TWENTY FOURTEEN SUPPORTS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO FIVE SIX.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO FIVE SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR S. B. TWO FIVE SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE VERO AT THE
TIME. AND I SHOW NO ONE SHOWING
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
TO OPPOSITION M. S. B. TWO FIVE
SIX. THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED S. B. TWO FIVE SIX
THERE IS NONE. FOR ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED SB
TWO FIVE SIX THERE IS NONE. FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SPEAK TO FIVE SIX BY
DR PAN. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THIS OPPOSITION FOR
SB TWO FIVE SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
DON'T THINK INITIAL OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO FOR SB
TWO FIVE SIX. AND EXCELLING
SHOWING OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
HAVE A TICKETS FOR AN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO FIVE
SIX ANSWERING OF QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
IS TO FIVE SIX TO GO TO
SUSPENSE. SB TWO SEVEN NINE BY
DOCTOR PAN ON MEDIC CAL
DELIVERY SYSTEM SERVICES THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE DR
PANDA'S WAY PRESENTATION. AND
WE WILL GO TO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN NINE
NINE. NINE AND IN THIS ROOM NOT
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TWO SEVEN NINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO SEVEN NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB TWO SEVEN NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO. AND IT'S NOT
SHOWING SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT WE WILL NOW
GO TO OPPOSITION S. B. TWO
SEVEN NINE AND AGAIN SIR. THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE THIS IS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. I'M HAPPY TO HEAR
THOSE THREE THINGS AND IF YOU
WOULD CONFINE YOURSELF TO THAT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES WE ARE
BEING PROPERLY CENSORED MY NAME
IS PAUL MAY GAVIN THE
ORGANIZATION IS WIRED AMERICA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
EVERY OTHER ONE IN THIS SHAM OF
A HEARING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THIS. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OTHER OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
OPPOSED WE'LL GO TO ASPEN
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
OPPOSED TO THE OP MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED S. B. TWO SEVEN NINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS
OPPOSITION PRESS B. TWO SEVEN
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I WANT TO GET INTO A
POSITION FOR SB TWO SEVEN NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND
IT'S NOT SHOWING UP WE DO
ACTUALLY ONE PERSON HAS JUST
PROPER LINE. COMPETITIONS ARE.
I DON'T TO ACTIVISION BURKE ALL
RIGHT HAVING OFFERED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE OPPOSED
AND SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN
NINE AND SEEING NO QUESTIONS.
OR COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO SEVEN
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON SB FIVE SIX EIGHT BY
DR PANA DEDUCTIBLES CHRONIC
DISEASE MANAGEMENT THIS IS A
SUSPENSE ITEM DR GRANT IS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. WE WILL GO
TO SUPPORT THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES SO WE'LL GO TO THE-
NAME ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION
PORTION OF OUR TECH PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE SIX
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE SIX EIGHTY
BAY PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE
TO HAVE QUEUED UP THE CURRENT
OPERATORS ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WAITING FOR THOSE TWO LINES AS
A REMINDER TO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE SIX EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE LINE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. LARA GAIN ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND THE NEXT
ONE IS COMING WITH AN OPERATOR
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
THIS IS FRED NO WE'RE GOOD
MORNING REPRESENTING FORMAT THE
SPONSOR OF SENATE BILL FIVE SIX
EIGHT URGING SUPPORT AS WELL AS
THE GOLDEN WEST CHAPTER OF THE
ALS ASSOCIATION URGING SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEVER MIND IF I DO
SO SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE SIX
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE SHOWING SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
WE WILL NOW MOVES OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE SIX STATUS OR ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM WISHING TO OPPOSE SB
FIVE SIX EIGHT. THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
OPPOSE IT WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S NO ONE
THERE MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB FIVE SIX
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IS
OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE SIX
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN THIS
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE TO
ZERO FOR SB FIVE SIX EIGHT. AND
I SHOW NO ONE SHOWING
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE SIX EIGHTEEN OH
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
THAT OBJECTIONS SB FIVE SIX
EIGHT WE'LL GO THROUGH SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON S. B. TWO EIGHTY NINE
BIND ON BY SENATOR NEWMAN ON
RECYCLING BATTERIES AND
BATTERY. EMBEDDED PRODUCTS THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THEIR
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WE
WILL GO TO TESTIMONY IF
SUPPORTERS NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE WISHING TO SUPPORT
SB TWO EIGHTY NINE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IN
SUPPORT OF TWO EIGHTY NINE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TWO EIGHT NINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO EIGHT NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON IN
Q. LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING. NUMBER IS
NOT ON- ON BEHALF OF YOUR LOCAL
COUNTY BOARD THANK YOU. AND AS
A REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
ISN'T SUPPORT FOR SB TWO EIGHT
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE WANTS SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WILL NOW MOVED OPPOSITION S. B.
TWO EIGHT NINE. NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM AT THE MICROPHONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION THIS B. TWO EIGHT
NINE REMOVED FROM TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
OPPOSED TO TWO EIGHT NINE-
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB TWO EIGHT NINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR IT SB TWO EIGHT
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I WANT TO GET IF YOU
OPPOSE SB TWO EIGHT NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THERE'S NO
ONE OPPOSING SB TWO EIGHT NINE.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE SPORT
IN OPPOSITION S. B. TWO A. NINE
THERE'S NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO EIGHT
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON SB SIX THREE SEVEN BY
SENATOR NEWMAN ON HEALTH
FACILITY REPORTING STAFFING.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION
WE'RE GOING TO SUPPORT
TESTAMENT IS NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
WISHING TO DO ME TOO IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX THREE SEVENTY NINE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SIX THREE
SEVEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SIX THREE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I WANT TO GET EACH
OF THE PORT FOR SB SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND
THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION- SB SIX THREE SEVEN
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
WILL COME BACK TO SPEAK TO ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE FOUR. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON SB
SIX THREE SEVEN. SIR PLEASE
CONFINE YOURSELF TO NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON SB
SIX THREE SEVEN THANK PAUL
MCGAVIN MY ORGANIZATION'S
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESS AND
I STAND IN. OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL NOT GIVING GIVEN AN AQ
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO OPPOSE SB SIX THREE SEVEN
SEEING NONE WERE MOVED AROUND
TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB. SIX
THREE SEVEN. CA.GOV OFFICIAL
OPPOSITION FOR SB SIX THREE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. DON'T FORGET TO
OPPOSE SB SIX THREE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND
I DON'T KNOW WHEN HE WAS HERE.
ALL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
THREE SEVEN ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
SB THREE THREE SIX BY CENTER
CHOI BO GUN PUBLIC HEALTH CODE
NINETEEN. THIS IS AN EMERGENCY
MATTER IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL MOVE INTO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SO IT'S NOW
THE TIME FOR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM WISHING TO DO THAT
HOW MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
FIGHTERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WISHING TO OFFER THEIR
POSITION. ON SB THREE THREE
SIX. LADIES AND IS ALSO FOR AT
THREE THREE SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO APPETITE. ONCE AGAIN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
THREE SIX THREE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AMAZON TO EXPORT ALL RIGHT WE
WERE MOVED OPPOSITION IS NO
PRIMARY WITNESS WE WERE
ACCOMPLISHING. WE'LL MOVE TO-
THOSE WISHING TO OFFER THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
POSITION ONLY ON S. B. THREE
THREE SIX IS NOW THE TIME TO
OFFER YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION YES MY NAME IS
PAUL MCGAVIN I REPRESENTS
CENSORED CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE NO IN THIS ROOM NO ONE
ELSE IN ROOM TENTY FORTY. TO
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB. THREE THREE SIX.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE
SHOPPERS UP IT IS ME TOO TO
OPPOSE SB THREE THREE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. I DON'T THINK INITIAL
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE THREE
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
IS NOT OPPOSING SB THREE THREE
FAX AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT OPPORTUNITIES AND THREE
THREE SIX EMAIL QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
IS TWO THREE THREE SIX WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB SIX
OH ONE BY SENATOR CHAU ABOVE
AND PERSONAL INCOME TAX
EXCLUSIONS CAPITAL GAINS SALES
AND RESIDENTS THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL MOVE
TO TESTIMONY SUPPORT THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SNAPPED TIME
FOR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE. SOMEBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING. TO
SUPPORT SB SIX OH ONE.
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT SB SIX OH ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT SB SIX OH ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND THERE'S
NO ONE SHOWING SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT IS NOW OPPOSITION TIME
FOR SB SIX OH ONE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S NO
ONE AT THE MICROPHONE WISHING
TO. OFFER THEIR TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION SB SIX OH ONE
REMOVED FROM TWENTY FORTY.
SEVEN IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
HUNTERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB SIX OH ONE. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX OH ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE ONE THAT'S A CUTE UP LINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REMEMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH
CORBIN KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM IS A
FEATURE. RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WHAT THE
CAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX OR ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE SHOWING
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB SIX A
ONE SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIX OH ONE. WILL GO TO SUSPEND
SPENDING ON SB THREE EIGHTY BY
SENATOR EGGMAN ON END OF LIFE.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN
THE AUTHOR HAS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF SB. THREE EIGHTY
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES SO
THERE WILL TAKE IT BACK TO THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SEVEN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. SUPPORT. OF
SB THREE EIGHTY. RELATED AND
GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. I DON'T THINK INITIAL
SUPPORT PLEASE PRES ONE ZERO
FOUR SB THREE EIGHTY. CENTERS
ON JOINT SUPPORT ALL RIGHT WELL
NOW MOVES OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE EIGHTY ON SENT FROM
SENATOR EGGMAN- THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SCHEDULED
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE OPPOSED SB THREE
EIGHTY IS OR ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NOW. BONTA RAIDER
PLEASE QUEUE OF ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB THREE
EIGHTY. LADIES AND IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK THE BEST PRESS THREE
EIGHTY PRESS ONE. AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. WE DID A
FEW BEST CUBA ONE OF THE PLANTS.
ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS TONY. WITH
CAPITAL RESEARCH INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE EIGHTY.
ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. NINE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS A MICHAEL
MCCABE BLESSED TO PROVE THIS AT
PARLIAMENT OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS DANIEL CONTEST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATIONS OR
INDEPENDENT INVENTORS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO BETWEEN. ZERO LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE. IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE EIGHTY. ENCINO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
EIGHTY WILL GO TO SUSPEND. THE
HONEST BEFORE- EIGHT. BY
SENATOR MAN ON INCOME AND
CORPORATE TAX CREDITS- THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SENATOR
MINUTES WAY PRESENTATION. MOVE
RIGHT TO. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY REPORTED TO ALL
THREE. NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MINORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. WISHING TO SUPPORT
SB FOUR OH EIGHT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT PRESS
BEFORE WAIT TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. WHAT THE CONDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR WAIT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PENICILLIN JOINT SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORTERS OR
ANYONE OPPOSED SB FOUR OH EIGHT
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
OPPOSE THIS BEFORE A WEIGHT BUT
WE WILL COME BACK TO FROM FORTY
TWO OR THREE FOR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION SIR
PLEASE SHARE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
AND I'D APPRECIATE IF YOU WOULD
CONFINE YOURSELF TO THOSE THREE
THINGS THANK YOU MY NAME IS
PAUL MCGAVIN MY ORGANIZATION IS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTING THE
BAGLEY KEENE ACT AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
THANK YOU. PERFECT ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN OPPOSITION AS BEFORE- EIGHT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION FOR
SB FOUR AWAIT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE IN Q. ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHEN MEMBERS
CATALINA SANCHEZ THE CARBON AND
TRY THEM BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM AT THE
STATION IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
I DON'T THINK INITIAL
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO FOUR SB FIVE AWAIT.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE AND USER
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE
AWAITING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
BEFORE A WASTE WILL GO TO
SUSPEND TO MOVE ON AS BEFORE
TWO FOUR BY SENATOR TO RAZA ON
TAX CREDITS. FOR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOMELESS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION- WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL GO TO
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
WITNESSES IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY COMING FORWARD WILL MOVE
CURRENT TWENTY FORTY. WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTIES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO SUPPORT SB FOUR TWO
FOUR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN CHAU
SUPPORT PRESS BEFORE TO FOR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. I ONCE
AGAIN YOU MAY SHOW SUPPORT BY
PRESSING ONE AT ZERO FOR SB
FOUR TWO FOUR. AND IT'S NOT
SHOWING SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR TWO FOUR. THERE'S NOBODY
AT THE MIKE IT IS NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE IN OPPOSITION OF
FOUR TO FOUR WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEVEN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE
THIS BEFORE TWO FOUR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS
BEFORE TO FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE IN Q. ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THAT UMBER HAD
LEFT ENTERED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION. ANY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
NEVER MIND OR BASED ON AMENDED
BECAUSE OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
TWO FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO. AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
THINK NOT TO MENTION. OUR I
HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR TO FOUR.
AND SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
BEFORE TWO FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPEND SPENDING HONESTY FIVE
SEVEN FIVE BY SENATOR RAZA ON
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITY
PERMITS. SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESS
SCHEDULED FOR SUPPORT WILL GO
TO NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION WITNESSES REPORTED TWO
OH THREE. THERE ARE NONE AT THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S NOBODY
THERE MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
FIVE SEVEN FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN CHAU SUPPORTER OF SB
FIVE SEVEN FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT THE
CONDITIONAL SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOU TOOK
YOURSELF OUT ACCUSED LIKE USUAL
SUPPORTED A PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE
DO HAVE ONE PARTICULAR CALLING
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE LINE TO CREATE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I THINK THEY'RE
COMING. HELLO THIS IS ERICA
MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF- TESTED
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
WHATEVER MIGHT OCCUR IF ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE'S USER. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SCHEDULED FOR
FIVE SEVEN FIVE WE WILL GO TO.
THIS ROOM FOR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ON SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME SIR
PLEASE TELL US YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
MY NAME IS PAUL MCGAVIN I
REPRESENT DEMORALIZED
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS SILENCED BY
IMPROPER SENATE PROCEDURES AND
WE'RE AGAINST THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
THIS ROOM PLEASE COME FORWARD
SIR YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION. MY NAME IS
ALEX CRONE I AM FOR
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST THE
IRRESPONSIBLE AND UNNECESSARY
PLACEMENT OF WIRELESS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FACILITIES
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE ARE ANYONE IN ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB FIVE
SEVEN FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE SEVEN
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
APPETITE. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD BEGIN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO FOR SB FIVE
SEVEN FIVE. THERE'S NO ONE IN
HOUSTON- ALL RIGHT HAVING TO
GET SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE SEVEN FIVE. AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT FIVE SEVEN FIVE GO TO
SUSPENSE FOR MOVING ON SB
FORCED TO EIGHT BY SENATOR HER
TADO ON HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
SCREENING. YOU'RE READY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. SB FOUR
TO EIGHT. I SEE NUMBER WHAT
CONSISTENT SUPPORT WAS TURNED A
ROOM FIVE TWENTY FORTY EIGHT
THERE ARE WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT
OF FOUR TO EIGHT I SEEN AND
SOME MODERATE PLEASE PROP
WITNESSES WHEN THE TESTIFYING
SUPPORT OF. CENTER HER FOR HER
DAUGHTER'S BEST BEFORE TO WAIT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH BECAUSE PART OF SB FOUR TO
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q.
SIR LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS A
DEMOCRATIC WITH CHILDREN NOW
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. FIVE
NEXT GENTLEMAN OF THE REMINDER
MY APOLOGIES IF YOU WERE TO
THINK OF THE PART OF SB FOUR TO
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THE TIME. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OKAY LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURE FOR
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE. MR MCAFEE ONE SHOULD COME
FORWARD IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE AND STATE YOUR OPPOSITION
AS BEFORE TO WAIT. MY NAME IS
PAUL MCGAVIN I REPRESENT A
PREVENT CHILD ENDANGERMENT FROM
WIRELESS SIGNALS BEYOND MY JUST
EIGHTY FIVE DBM AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BEFORE TWO EIGHT. NAME IS ALEX
BROWN AND I'M FOR CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST THE- UNNECESSARY
FORCEFUL FUNDS OF UNSAFE
TECHNOLOGY IN THAT OF MICROWAVE
RADIATION A KNOWN CARCINOGEN
AND NEUROTOXIN AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU HYPERGATE
SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF. IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WAS TRYING TO
ROOMS DOT TWENTY FORTY EIGHT
FEMALE MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION OF
AS BEFORE TO WAIT MODERATOR FOR
PLEASE PROP WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FORTY WAIT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OPPOSITION PRESS FOUR TO EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND IF YOUR MIND IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
BUT NO RESPONSE WE RELEASING
LINE TWENTY SEVEN. THERE'S NO
ONE I THINK YOU SIR OKAY WILL
BRING BACK TO MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS LEGISLATION
ON ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE
SCREENING SEEING NONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AS BEFORE C<c.cyan></c>
DISMISSES SUSPENSE COUNTERED-
THE NEXT ITEM UP IS CENTER HER
TAUGHT US AS PEOPLE FOR. NINE
TWO REGARDING WITH MATERNAL
HEALTH THIS ITEM IS SUSPENSE
CANCER CHEAT CANDID SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO THREE TESTS FIND
SUPPORT OF. THIS BEFORE. NINETY
YC NINE ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FOUR A SINGLE MEMBERS
TESTIFYING THERE'S SOME
MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE PROP
WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR NINE
TWO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO PICK UP THE PART OF
SB FOUR NINE TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD BECAUSE PART OF SB
FOUR NINE TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. ANDERSON
WANTED TO PARTNER ALL RIGHT
LET'S TO PULL THE SAME
PROCEDURES FOR OPPOSITION IS AN
IMPORTANT. ANY WITNESSES HERE
AND ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION. SB FOUR
NINETY MISS MCGOVERN PLEASE
COME FORWARD. MY NAME IS PAUL
MCGAVIN I REPRESENT THANK YOU
SENATOR Y. CASKEY FOR GIVING
THE PUBLIC SOME VOICE IN THIS
HEARING WE APPRECIATE IT VERY
MUCH AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD NEXT. MY NAME IS ALEX
CRONENBERG- REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST TAKING
AWAY LOCAL JURISDICTION AND THE
ABILITY TO CONTROL THE
PLACEMENT OF WIRELESS
TELECOMMUNICATION FACILITIES
OUTSIDE OF OUR CHILDREN'S
BEDROOM WINDOW AND WE OPPOSE
THIS RESTAURANT OKAY LET'S SEE
NO OTHER WITNESSES AND ROOM FOR
TWO OR THREE OPTION OF ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OR SEEN A
WITNESSES THEIR MODERATOR FOR
PLEASE PROP WITNESSES WHEN THEY
TESTIFY IN A POSITION OF S. B.
FOUR NINE TWO ONE. MATERNAL
HEALTH. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
FOR SB FOUR NINE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THERE ARE LOTS OF
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
OPPOSE SB FOUR NINE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND THERE'S
NO ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION OKAY
WILL BRING AFFECTED THIS TO ANY
OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
ON. THIS BILL WITHOUT OBJECTION
HAS BEFORE NINE TWO IS THE
SUSPENSE CALENDAR. NEXT UP ON
OUR AGENDA IS CENTER FOR TITLES
S. B. FOUR SIX EIGHTH REGARDING
CARE CENTERS. THIS ITEM IS
DISPENSED CANDOR AND SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION THERE ANY
WITNESSES. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FOUR EIGHT. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE C. NINE I SEE
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
ROOM. TWENTY FORTY TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORCE. SIX
FOUR EIGHT MODERATE YOU PLEASE
TO WITNESSES. WE THE TESTIFYING
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR SB SIX FOUR EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THE TIME.
WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. THEIR
CRIME WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. BOTHER WAITING
FOR THAT LINE IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX FOUR EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE PLAN SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
BOB NEAL REPRESENTING SIX BY
THE INCA ORGANIZATION OF MORE
THAN TWO THOUSAND ASSISTED
LIVING HOMES WHO ARE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY FOR THIS BILL.
GIVE US NAYLOR OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME LET'S TURN
OPPOSITION- WITNESSES PRESENT
HERE IN A ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
FOUR EIGHT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
PLEASE COME FORWARD. STATE YOUR
POSITION. YEAH MY NAME IS PAUL
MCGANN FOR CALIFORNIANS IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
BEING PUT BACK ON THE NEXT
APPROPRIATIONS AGENDA AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL- AGAIN. PART
SEEING. MR CAME PLEASE COME FOR
START MR CROWN I OPPOSE I AM
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST- SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
IN DIGGING UP OUR LOOK STREETS
AND- TAKING AWAY LOCAL
AUTHORITY AWAY FROM- AT THE
CITY'S WHO KNOW WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR CITIES THAT'S WHY SO OIL
IN. A IN OUR- COASTAL CITIES IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE SOIL IN HOPE
AND THAT WAS TAKEN OFF THE BILL
I LEFT A NEWBORN CHILD AT HOME
TO COME TALK ON THREE SEVEN
EIGHT AND FOR SOME REASON IT
WAS TAKEN OFF TODAY JOE FOUR
HOURS FOR THIS AND I FEEL LIKE
I WAS OUT I SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SB SIX
FORTY BY HER TADO WITH ROOM TO
THE ROOM FIVE TWENTY FORTY I
SEE NO OPPOSITION THERE
MODERATE IF YOU PLEASE PROP
WITNESSES. WITHIN THE TESTIFIED
IN OPPOSITION OF. SB SIX FOUR
EIGHT. CERTAINLY WAITED UNTIL
IF YOU WISH TO IT UP AND- TO SB
SIX POINT EIGHT YOU MAY. ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MORE AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FOUR
EIGHT THREE SEVEN ONE THAT. IS
RIGHT. THERE'S NO ONE HERE TO.
ABOUT THE STATE. YEAH ALL RIGHT
A GOOD DO ANY MEMBERS THE- HAVE
ON AN TO SUBMIT WITHOUT A CHECK
SB SIX FOUR EIGHT IS MY TO
SUSPENSE ACCOUNT. SENATE DO YOU
HAVE SEVERAL BILLS IN YOUR YEAH
SB FIVE ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
ELEMENTAL SERVICES SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM IS
ASSISTANCE COUNTERING YOU'VE
PLAYED PRESENTATION TO LET'S
MOVE TO THE PUBLIC IS FOR
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE EIGHTEEN SAYING THAT
AND I SEE NO WITNESSES A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF FIVE EIGHTEEN TO
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT THE
WITNESSES WERE IN THE
TESTIFYING TELECONFERENCE LINE
IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. FIVE ONE
EIGHT. AND WAITED ON IF YOU
WISH TO SELL. BECAUSE SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE ONE EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE ONE IN Q. THIRD LINE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WILL CRIME
COSPONSORED. THE FIVE ONE EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE ONE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE PHILADELPHIA
PART BURKE GOOD LET'S FALL THE
SAME PROCEDURE IN HERE FROM
OPPOSITION THAT THE WITNESSES.
ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FIVE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE COME FOR MR DAM
YEAH MY NAME IS PAUL MCADAM FOR
CALIFORNIA IS IN SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT CODE ONE
ONE ONE TWO OF THERE NEEDS TO
BE A SEAT AT THE TABLE RESERVED
FOR THE PUBLIC AND WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
RETURN. HEARING NO OTHER.
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM ALL
THE ROOMS ABOUT TWENTY FORTY. I
SEE NO WITNESSES HERE IN.
OPPOSITION OF. SB FIVE EIGHTEEN
MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE PROP
ANY WITNESSES WILLING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
FIVE EIGHTEEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE ONE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU OPPOSE SB FIVE ONE EIGHT
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
I DON'T KNOW WHEN OPPOSING BILL
LET'S BRING BACK THE- CENTER
LAYERED THE AUTHOR OF SB FIVE
ONE EIGHT YOUR RECORD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE WITNESS AND SUPPORT
AND SAY THAT I BELIEVE THE-
COST LISTED IN ANALYSIS WAS
VERY. INFLATED AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE STAFF ON THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE ABILITY TO
CONDUCT. VERY GOOD WITHOUT
FURTHER OBJECTION SB FIVE
EIGHTEEN IS THE SUSPENSE
COUNTER CENTER BRADFORD HAS A
BILL. SB FIVE TO ONE THIS IS
ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDID IN HIS
WAY PRESENTATION ON DRUG
MANUFACTURERS AND VALUE BASED.
ARRANGEMENTS IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE IN THE PUBLIC AND ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE TWO
ONE SEEING THAT I TURNED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FIVE TO ONE SO.
MODERATE POLICE PROPER
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY ON
A TELECONFERENCE. LINE SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE TO ONE. AND WE INTO
IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT FIVE TO
ONE PRESS AND. ZERO I WANT TO
GET A REPORT SB FIVE TWO ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THE TIME. THERE'S NO ONE AT THE
PORT. ALRIGHT LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCEDURE FOR THE
OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES
PRESENT HERE AND ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. AND OPPOSITION OF
FIVE. TO ONE MR KEVIN YOU
RECOGNIZE. MY NAME IS PAUL
MCGANN AND REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM SENATOR MCCASKEY WHY
POINTS OF ORDER ARE NOT ALLOWED
IN THIS PROCEEDING. AND WE
OPPOSE THE BILL. I SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF. SB
FIVE TO ONE HERE WILL BE MOVED
TO ROOM FOUR TWENTY FORTY
EIGHTEEN WITNESSES HERE SO
MODERATE IF YOU'LL PROP. OF THE
WITNESSES WHEN THE TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE TO ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE TWO ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. DON'T
FORGET IF YOU OPPOSE SB FIVE
TWO ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO. AND I CHAU NOT OPPOSING
ABOUT WILL BRING YOU BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS OUR HANDS REYES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE TWO
ONE IS DISPENSED COUNTER.
CENTER LABOR HAS BILL- S. B.
FIVE TWO THREE GUARDING HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE AND
CONTRACEPTIVES. THIS IS A ALSO
A SUSPENSE CANDID SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN ROME FORTY TWO THROUGH
THE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. FIVE TWO THREE SEEING
NONE I SEE NO WITNESSES A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THIRD FIND
SUPPORT. SMARTER PLEASE PROMPT
WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY ON
A TELECONFERENCE LINE SUPPORT.
OF SB FIVE TO THREE. A LADY AND
GENTLEMEN ANGELA PART OF AN
FIVE TO THREE MAY PRESS ONE TO.
AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE IN
Q. ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RICHARD CHAIRMAN SENATOR
WILLIAM BURKE ON BEHALF OF
BALLING. NAY WRAPPED CHOICE
CALIFORNIA I A SPONSOR. AND THE
CAL NURSE MIDWIFE. IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. OKAY NEXT AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AGAIN PRESS IF
ZERO YOUR SUPPORT OF SB TO
THREE. THAT'S RIGHT I THOUGHT
THE ONE I IN SUPPORT. WITH
SAMPLED AGES DO THAT WITH THE
SAME. FOR UP TO. DO HAVE ANY
I'M SORRY MY BIRTHDAY JUST-
WHAT'S YOUR THE US. UNDER
CURRENT OPERATOR- ANOTHER
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE LINE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS A CAPITAL OFFENSE AFFECT HOW.
OUTPUT ON AT. ANY. THANK YOU.
ANYONE OUT MODERATOR TO ONE OF.
NO ONE ELSE IN TWO SEPARATE
OKAY WHAT'S FALLS PROCEDURE FOR
THE UP OF ANYWAY PER ROOM FORTY
TWO THREE AND OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TO THREE MISTER MCGAVIN
PLEASE COME FORWARD. FINER'S
PALMA GAVEL FOR CALIFORNIA'S IN
SUPPORT AND THANKS OF SENATE
SECURITY WHO ACT CONSISTENTLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC EVERY
DAY THAT THEY WORK HERE AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION OF AS BEING FIVE
THREE C. NINE IN ROOM TWENTY
THREE OF FORTY TWO OR THREE
WILL TURN TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
I SEE NO OPPOSITION. TO SB FIVE
TO THREE THEIR MODERN- PLEASE
PROP ANY WITNESSES. WE NEED
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE TO THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU OPPOSE SB FIVE
TO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THEY WANT TO GET
TO OPPOSED SB FIVE TO THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I DO HAVE ONE IN Q.
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE PLAN SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TELL YOUR
VOLATILE CAPITAL FLOWS INTO
JUNE IN OPPOSITION SB FIVE.
THANK YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AFTER ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE TO THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I SHOW NO ONE ELSE OPPOSING THE
BILL. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
WITNESSES AND I SEE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS ON A
DANCE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
TWO THREES. TO SUSPENSE
CALENDAR. CENTER WOMAN IS AN
EX- SENATOR HAS A BILL SB FIVE
FORTY WHICH IS VEHICLE LICENSE
FEES FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CALENDAR INCHES AWAY
PRESENTATION ON THIS MEASURE
SEVERAL OTHER WITNESSES HERE
IN. ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. S. B.
FIVE FOUR CHU I SEEN AND I SEE
NO WITNESSES FROM ROOM. TWENTY
FORTY TESTS FIND SUPPORTS
MODERATOR FEW PRES PROMPT ANY
WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY
AND TELECONFERENCING LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF S. FIVE FOUR Q. THE-
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH BECAUSE THE PART OF SB
FIVE FOUR TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE IN Q. CRAWLING WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
BORDER WAITING FOR THAT LINE OF
THE REMINDER IF YOU WOULD
BECAUSE OF SB FIVE FOUR TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE SEVENTY ONE IF
YOU'RE SHOWING SUPPORT YOU TOOK
YOURSELF OUT A Q. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. THE PHILADELPHIA
USER ALREADY LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCEDURE FOR THE
OPPOSITIONAL RENDON WITNESSES
IN ROOM. FORTY TWO THREE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE FOUR
TWO MISTER DEVON PLEASE BEFORE.
MYERS PALMA GAVIN I'M WITH
CALIFORNIANS TO SUPPORT THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN RULE
AMENDMENTS TO THE AMERICAN WITH
DISABILITIES ACT AND PROPER
TRAINING OF SENATE STAFF TO
APPLY THOSE RULES TO THESE
PROCEEDINGS THAT WERE AGAINST
THE BILL. EXCELLENT PAGE
WITNESS. MY NAME IS ALEX CRONIN
I'M REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS
FOR MAKING- BROADBAND WIRED
CONNECTION A PUBLIC UTILITY AND
AGAINST CORPORATE GIVEAWAYS TO
WIRELESS CORPORATIONS TO RIP US
OFF AND WE OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU OKAY SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THE
ROLE TURNED ROOM TWENTY FORTY I
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHICH IN A TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FOUR TWO
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROPERTY WITNESSES WAITING ON
THE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO
TESTIFY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE FOUR TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO FOR SB FIVE
FOUR TWO. I TOTALING OPPOSING
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS I SEE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS WHO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. S. B. FIVE
FOUR TWO. IS THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR. CONTINUE OUR FISCAL
REVIEW WITH MOVE TO CENTER
LEMOND'S SB FIVE FIVE THREE ON
INCOME TAX CALIFORNIA WORK
OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT WHICH
IS. ALSO AN ITEM. OR SUSPENSE
CANDID AND SHE'S WAY PART
PRESENTATION SO OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN ROOM FORTY TWO
THREE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIVE THREE I SEE NONE I SEE NO
WITNESSES. IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
TESTIFYING SUPPORTS MODERATE-
CAN YOU PLEASE PROMPT WITNESSES
WAITING TESTIFIED ON A
TELECONFERENCE LINE SUPPORT OF
S. P. FIVE FIVE THREE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SELL SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE FIVE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. WHAT THE INITIAL
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT.
ZERO I DON'T KNOW IMPORTING
ABOUT OKAY LET'S MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM FORTY TWO THREE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
THREE MISPRINT KEVIN PLEASE
COME FORWARD STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS. CALIFORNIA
WORK OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT
MEASURE MY NAME'S PAUL MCGAVIN
I'M WITH CALIFORNIANS WHO WISH
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPETE FAIRLY AND DELIBERATING
ON THESE BILLS AND WE SUPPORT
WE DO NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
OPPOSE IT THANK YOU. EXCELLENT
MARTINO OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN HERE AND FORTY TO
THREE IN OPPOSITION MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SENIOR
MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION OF. SB
FIVE FIVE THREE SOME MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT. THE WITNESSES
WHEN THEY TESTIFY IN A POSITION
OF SB. FIVE FIVE THREE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
BY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. I WANT TO GET TO
OPPOSED BY FIVE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. SO NO ONE
APPOINTED ABOUT SPRING FACT MAY
I SEE NO HAN SEPARATE QUESTIONS
REGARDING OF FIVE FIVE THREE SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT MEMBERS.
THAT MEASURES MUST DISPENSE
FAULT FILE. ITEM OF THE AGENDA
SAYS B. FIVE SIX OH BY CENTER
RUBIO TO CLIMATE POLLUTION
REDUCTION IN HOMES INITIATIVE
GRANTS. IT IS A SUSPENSE CANADA
ISSUES WE PRESENTATION OF THE
WITNESSES. HERE. ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE TO. THAT'S WHY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIX OH I
NONE I SEE NO WITH MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN. TWENTY FORTY. IN
SUPPORT OF. SB FIVE SIX A
MODERATE FUTURE PROP WITNESSES
WE NEED TESTIFIED A
TELECONFERENCE LINE SUPPORT OF.
SB FIVE SIX SO. PLEASE ENTER
SILVA POR OF SB SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND. AND ONCE AGAIN
IT'LL DEPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO ZERO FOR SB FIVE SIX ZERO.
SPECIAL OLYMPICS PORTING ABOUT.
GOODNESS FALL THE SAME
PROCEDURE FOR THE OPPOSITION OF
THE WITNESSES. THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SIX
OUT. MISMA KEVIN PLEASE COME
FORWARD. MY NAME IS PAUL
MCGAVIN IS THERE A POSSIBILITY
FOR POINT WHERE CAN WE ASK A
QUESTION TONIGHT THANK YOU AND
SO I AM HERE FOR CALIFORNIANS
WHO WOULD WISH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE A POINT OF ORDER AND-
WE OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES MR TRUMP
PLEASE COME FORWARD. ALEX CROWN
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO UNDERSTAND
THE REASON WE HAVE A DIGITAL
DIVIDE IS BECAUSE OF MONOPOLIES
LIKE VERIZON AND AT&T AND
GIVING THEM. A LITTLE UNLIMITED
AUTHORITY IS ONLY GONNA MAKE
THAT WORSE AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY GOOD SEEING
THE WEATHER- INDIVIDUALS
TESTIFYING. IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE PEOPLE TO ROOM TWENTY
FOUR DAYS YOU KNOW WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB FIVE SIX OH
SO MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT WITNESSES WHEN
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE SIX OF. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TO
CALL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE SB FIVE SIX ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT OPPOSING ABOUT EARLY
SPRING BACK TO MENDOCINO HANDS
UP SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
SIX IT WAS MOVED TO SUSPENSE
CALENDAR. CENTER RUBIO HAS SB
SEVEN TWO THREE ON THE PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TUTORING PROGRAM
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION THIS
ITEM IS ALSO SPENDS KANDINSKY'S
WE'VE- PRESENTATION. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES HERE ROOM FORTY
TWO THREE TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. SEVEN TWO I SEE NONE.
I TURN I SEE NO WITNESSES TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY TEST
SUPPORTER. SB SEVENTY THREE SO
MODERATOR PLEASE PROP WITNESSES
WAITING TESTIFIED. ON A
TELECONFERENCE LINE SUPPORT OF.
SB SEVEN TWO THREE. AND LADIES
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT THE PORT OF SB FIVE TWO
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
ACTED. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD JUST OF SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO FOR SB SEVEN
TWO THREE. AND I CHAU KNOWLEDGE
THE POINT IN THE BILL VERY GOOD
LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURE
FOR OPPOSITION OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVN TO
THREE. PLEASE COME FORWARD. MY
NAME IS PAUL MCGAVIN I
REPRESENT CALIFORNIANS WHO
SUPPORT. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE STAFF
ACTUALLY RESPONDING TO EMAILS
AND VOICEMAILS. FASTER THAN
STONEWALLING FOR EIGHT DAYS AND
WE OPPOSE THE BILL VERY COULD.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION ON. IN
ROOM TWENTY THREE OF. FORTY TWO
THREE ARE TRYING TO WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY GUESS YOU
KNOW WHEN THIS IS THERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SEVEN TWENTY
THREE SOME MODERATOR. WITH
PLEASE PROP WITNESSES WILLING
TO TESTIFY IN A POSITION OF SB.
SEVEN TWO THREE. BASICALLY AND
GENTLEMEN THIS OP TO SB TWO
THREE PLEASE ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
DON'T KNOW ONCE YOU START.
RIGHT HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. THIS IS SB SEVEN
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO
WITH CHECK IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AND HAVING HEARD
NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS
BILL SHALL GO TO SAYS FENCE.
HOLD ON ONE SEC.
SO JUST TO
RECAP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR
RUBIO WENT TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON SB SIX OH SEVEN BY GENERAL
ROCK ON PROFESSORS AND VOCATION
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL GO TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX OH SEVEN THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SO WE WILL GO
TO THE MICROPHONE. FOR ANYBODY
WHO IS HERE TO GIVE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN SUPPORT
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE PLEASE QUEUE UP
THE PHONE LINE FOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH SEVEN BY
GENERAL ROTH. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO FULL
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX ZERO SEVEN
YOU MADE PRESS ONE ZERO ACTIVE
TIME. WHAT THE CONDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX ZERO SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND I
SHOW NO ONE'S POINTING THAT OUT
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX OH SEVEN
AND- PRIMARY WITNESSES. SO
WE'LL COME BACK TO THIS ROOM
FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIMONY TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX OH SEVEN. THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION SIR
PLEASE COME UP. SHARE YOUR NAME
YOUR POSITION IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION. MY NAME'S PALMER
GAVIN I REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO RECOGNIZED
THAT SB FIVE FIVE SIX ONE THREE
SEVEN EIGHT HAVE STRONG FISCAL
IMPACT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
SIR WE ARE NOT ON THOSE BILLS.
YOU KNOW. WHAT IS HOLD ON ONE
SECOND IF YOU GUYS CAN CONFINE
YOUR TESTIMONY TO THE BILL AT
HAND THAT WOULD BE GOOD IF
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE PROBLEMS
SO. WEIRD WEEK RIGHT NOW IT'S
S. B. SIX OH SEVEN ON
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS IF
YOU HAVE A POSITION ON THAT
BILL. PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON SB SIX OH SEVEN.
ALEX CROWN FOR REVISION
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST THE
PLACEMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
WIRELESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
RESIDENTIAL ZONES AND WE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE WILL GO NOW
TO ROOM FORTY SIX IN THE.
TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY'S THERE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE WHERE
ON SB. SIX OH SEVEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN SHOT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX ZERO SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE SB
SIX OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I DON'T KNOW ONE OPPOSING
THE BILL FOR OUR I HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION SB SIX
OH SEVEN- AND SIGNAL QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIX OH SEVEN WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB
SEVEN SEVENTY BY GENERAL ROTH
AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND PATHWAYS TO LAW
SCHOOL PROGRAM. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
GENERAL'S WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
WILL GO TO SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN
THIS ROOM ON SB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTIES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN. AT TEN THIRTY
SEVEN SEVEN ZERO. FOUR AT.
SEVEN SEVEN ZERO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. I WANT TO GET A
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND I SAW ANOTHER SUPPORTING
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW
MOVES OPPOSITION THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IF ANYBODY
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON. BILL
SEVEN SEVEN ZERO. THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
BILL. SEVEN SEVEN ZERO. MY NAME
IS PAUL MCGAVIN REPRESENTING
MILLIONS OF ELECTROMAGNETIC
SENSITIVE CALIFORNIANS WAS PART
OF OUR TOWN OUR CHOICE AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. SEE
NO ONE ELSE COMING MICROPHONE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY FORTY NOW
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO S. B. SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SEVEN SEVEN ZERO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE SB SEVEN
SEVEN ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. AND I SHOW NO ONE
OPPOSED TO THE AUTHOR ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO I HAVE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
SEVEN ZERO. FOUR GO TO SUSPENSE
WILL MOVE ON SB EIGHT HUNDRED
BY JENNA ROTH ON REAL ESTATE
LICENSING THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE GENERAL WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL GO TO
THIS ROOM FOR. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
WITNESSES THERE NO HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTIES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
WISHING TO SUPPORT SB. EIGHT
HUNDRED. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT HUNDRED YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT HUNDRED.
AND THEY DON'T SUPPORTING THE
BILL AT THE TIME. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW MOVES OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT HUNDRED THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SB
EIGHT HUNDRED. SIR WE'RE TAKING
OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON SB EIGHT
HUNDRED. HE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON SB EIGHT HUNDRED NOW
IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY. FIND REAL
ESTATE LICENSING YES CORRECT MY
NAME IS PAUL MAKE GAVIN AND I
REPRESENT MANY PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO PRESERVE THE QUIETUDE
ENJOYMENT OF ST SUCH UNSAFE AT
ANY G. DOT COM. WE MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S
NOBODY THERE ANYONE FOR NINE
OPPOSED SB. EIGHT HUNDRED.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AT THE EIGHT HUNDRED YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT HUNDRED
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. I
SAW NO ONE OPPOSING THE DOCTOR-
ALL RIGHT WE TAKE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
AS FROM NOPE FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
HUNDRED WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. SB
EIGHT OH ONE GENERAL RAKAN
HEALING ARTS QUARTER BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL MOVE
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH ONE
THERE IS NO ONE WILL MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT.
OF SB EIGHT OH ONE. AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TALK
ABOUT FOR S. B. A. R. ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THE- AT THIS TIME.
AND WANT TO GET A JOB SUPPORT
YOU PRESS ZERO AT THE FOR AT
YOU DON'T WANT. AND I SHOW NOT
WANT SUPPORTING THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT WE MOVED. S. B. OH ONE.
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN. OF S. B. A ONE WILL COME TO
THIS ON A B. OH ONE AND HE'LL
ARTS. FOR NAME. AND POSITION.
FIRST LADIES AND GENTLEMAN YOU
WISH TO ABOUT THE TO EIGHT ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN THEY
DON'T KNOW SIR MY MA'AM WE'RE
IT THIS FOR SO. CIRCULAR MY
NAME IS PAUL MCGANN AND WE SAW.
ALL HIGH OF SAFETY FOR YOU VERY
MUCH WE SUPPOSE THANK YOU- THE
BILL'S THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NO ONE ELSE THE MIKE WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO
NOBODY THERE MONTEREY NOW IS
THE OPPORTUNE TO KEEP UP ANYWAY
OPPOSE TO ASK. EIGHT ONE. THANK
YOU SIR BUT AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU TO SPEAK UP AT THE TO ASK
EIGHT OR YOU MADE. ONE ZERO. I
WANT TO GET TO OPPOSE AT INTO
ONE YOU MADE ONE ZERO THIS TIME.
I SHOWN ONE OPPOSE ABOUT OUR
HAVING THE- FOR BOTH AND I. OF
S. B. OH ONE IN SINGAPORE FROM
COLLEAGUES. WITHOUT OBJECTION
ZERO ONE WILL GO TO MOVIE
HONEST EIGHT OH TWO GENERAL
ROCK CLOSER AT. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE THE WHERE. THERE
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL COME
BACK TO THIS YEAR FOR NAME. OF
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHT
OH TWO. AND LADIES AND JOHN IF
YOU WOULD OF THE PORT OF S. B.
EIGHT OUT PLEASE. ONE ZERO OF
TIME. ONCE AGAIN OF THE FOR SB
EIGHT OLD PLEASE. ONE ZERO. AND
EXCELLING IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION OF
S. B. EIGHT OH TWO ONE PRIVATE
POSTS SECONDARY. OR NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. ANYONE WITH TO OUR
THEIR NAY THERE ARE. AND THEIR
PLACE ON THIS EIGHT OH PLEASE
COME FOR. MY NAME'S PALMER. FOR
K. WITH RESULTS TO FOR ALL OF
OUR- IN THE LEAD. PROCESS OUR
RIGHTS AND WE OPPOSED BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR ANYONE
ELSE KNOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE MODERATOR IN
OPPOSITION SB EIGHT OH TWO. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHT OH TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE IN CUBA CALLING WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
LINE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. SENATORS FRED JONES
ON BEHALF OF THE PROFESSIONAL
BEAUTY FEDERATION CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. NEVER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW UP TO SB
DON'T YOU MAY BE ONE AND. AND I
KNOW WHAT I'M SUPPOSED THE
DOCTOR ALL RIGHT HAVE A TAKE
SUPPORT OPPOSITE HONEST EIGHT
OH TWO AND CA FROM COLLEAGUES A
LOT OF. SB OH TWO WILL GO TO
SEE. MOVING THAT SB A OH THREE
BY GENERAL ROTH ON BAR IN
BECAUSE- THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE CANDID. AND THE AUTHOR
WAY PER. THERE NO PRIMARY WE IN
SUPPORT SO WE'LL GO TO THE ROOM
TO SEE IF THERE'S A HERE NAME.
AND BECAUSE- SEEING NONE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM TO FOUR THERE'S NO
THERE. MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE WISHING TO SEE. S. B. A.
OH THREE ON. AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH SHELVE FOR A EIGHT
THREE MAY PRESS ONE AT THE
AFTER TIME. WE DO HAVE.
PARTICIPANT IN Q. ONE MOMENT.
THE CARD WITH ANOTHER. LONG
WAITING FOR THAT LINE INTO.
MINOR WE NEED TO MANAGE SUPPORT
YOU. MAY PRESS. AND WILL
ACCOMMODATE YOU BUT AGAIN IT'S
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION. MODERATES OR
ANYONE ELSE. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ELSE IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT IF
THAT PERSON COMES BACK ONLINE
WILL ACCOMMODATE THEM- AND
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION SB EIGHT
OH THREE ON BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WE WILL GO TO
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
ON EIGHT OH THREE WHICH IS ON
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
PLEASE SIR COME SHARE YOUR
POSITION. MY NAME IS PAUL
MCGAVIN WITH WAKE UP AMERICA
YOU'RE WATCHING AGENDA TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY THIRTY
BEING VOTED IN RIGHT NOW AND WE
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE KNOW
WHO MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY. THERE MONTEREY
IS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSED AS EIGHT OF OR IF WE
FOR THAT PERSON WHO SUPPORT OF
IT- THIS WOULD BE QUEUE THEM UP
AS WELL. OKAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN YOU WISH TO. SB OH
THREE YOU MADE. ONE ZERO THIS
TIME. HELLO PLEASE. THAT'S THE
SAME PER. BERMAN BONTA LINES
PER LINE THREE MIND ABOUT
GERMAN TO A FRED- OF THE BEAUTY
FOR CAL OPPOSING THIS. REFORM
OF ORINDA TANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE. PROPOSED SB EIGHT
OH THREE. AS A MATTER WAITING
TO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN TO
SB A OR THREE MAY PRESS AT ZERO
AT THE TIME. AND I SAW KNOW
WHAT OFTEN OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT TAKE IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND FOR ONE. WITH
THAT. OF THEY COME ON LATER
WILL ACCOMMODATE THEM. A SINGLE
QUESTION FOR MICHAEL THAT A- IS
EIGHT OF. WILL GO TO SYSTEM.
MOVING FTA DOES. BY ROTH AND
HIS. ASSISTANT THIS IS A SYSTEM
CANNOT. AND THE AUTHOR WAY PER.
WILL THERE ARE NO FOR. WOULD
WILL TO TEST AND SAID. OF NAY
MORTGAGE. IN POSITION. NOBODY
HERE THIS FROM A ROOM TO FORTY.
TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WHICH TO SERVE. SB EIGHT OH SO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF OP
APART SB A AFFECTS PRESS AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN ONE AGAIN
IT'S OF FOR A EIGHT OH SIX
PRESS AND THEIR- AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN PARK. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO. ON S. B. EIGHT
SIX. WHICH IS A- SUS. BILL
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITH THIS
IS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO YOUR
NAME YOU'RE GONNA AND YOUR-
THIS IS THE- CAMANCHE. TELL US
YOUR NAME YOUR GOING TO. AD
YOUR BECAUSE- BY HIS PALM GAVIN
I. COUNTY WHO IT OUT TO THE END
INVITE YOU TO RETURN OUR CALLS.
PORTANTINO AND WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING ON TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
NOBODY THERE WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT OH SIX. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT OH
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT ZERO
AT THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO SB IT'LL SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
SPECIAL NOTE OPPOSING THE
DOCTOR ARE HAVING TAKE MY-
BUDGET THAT. ONE YET I
APOLOGIZE NINE SEVEN FOUR-
COLLECTED WITHIN ONE PLEASE.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE LINE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR MIND OPEN. GOOD
MORNING I'M BACK FOR CALIFORNIA
EIGHT ZERO THREE CALIFORNIA'S
MEDICAL RYAN OPPOSES ARE AT I
APPROVED IF A MAN THANK YOU YOU. ARE WE ARE ON SB
EIGHT OH SIX OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE MODERATOR.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE SHOWING UP
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN IN OPPOSITION OF
ASSOCIATE- OH SIX SEEING NONE
AND SENIOR QUESTIONS MY CALL
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT OH
SIX GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON S.
B. SIX TEN BY ENATOR GROVE ON
PERSONAL INCOME TAX. CREDIT
VIRTUAL LEARNING COSTS THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OBVIOUS WAY PRESENTATION THERE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
THIS ROOM THERE ARE NONE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTIES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX TEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX TEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. I DON'T
KNOW WHEN IT'S- ALL RIGHT THERE
IS NO ONE IN SUPPORT WILL MOVE
COMPOSITION OF SB SIX TEN
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY BATTERIES OR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION SB SIX
TENTHS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I
SHOWED MY POSITION TO ASK THESE
TEN MAY PRESS ONE AND AT. ONCE
AGAIN THE SHOPPING TO A SIX YOU
BATES ONE THEN. AND I SHOULD
WANT TO PUT ABOUT. ALL RIGHT WE
TO SUPPORT NOW. OPPORTUNE AND
SB SIXTY WE HAVE NO QUESTION
ARE FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB SIX TEN WILL GO
TO SUSPEND. MOVING ON SB SIX
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR HUESO
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY AN OUTDOOR
ACCESS SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION. AND WE
WILL GO TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NO MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY FOUR.
LADIES GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT SB
THREE TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAT THE- AT THIS TIME. I WANT
TO GET EACH FOR AT SIX TWO YOU
MAY ONE ZERO. SPECIAL NO ONE IN
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW
MOVE TOP. OF S. B. C. TWENTY.
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM.
OPPOSING SIX TWENTY FORCING
KNOWN AT THE MICROPHONE. SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB SIX TWENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR HUESO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX TWO
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX TWO FOR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO. ACTUALLY NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX TWENTY FOUR. AND NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX TWENTY
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVIE
ON SB SIX NINETY SEVEN ON CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM FOR GREEN
HYDROGEN CREDIT PROGRAM. A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. THERE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES AND WILL
VOTED WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NINE FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE
ARE NONE WE'LL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE ARE NONE.
BOUNDARIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX NINE SEVEN BY SENATOR HUESO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SELL SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT. ONE ZERO THIS
TIME. WHAT THE INITIAL SUPPORT
FOR SB SIX NINE SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I SHOW NO ONE IN SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX NINE SEVEN
BY SENATOR HUESO. ON CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM GREEN HYDROGEN-
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO SB SIX NINETY SEVEN
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. FIGHTERS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB. SIX
NINE SEVEN. BUT IF AND
GENTLEMEN BECAUSE- OF S. B. C.
NINE SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
TO. AT THIS. ONCE AGAIN THIS UP
AND TO S. B. C. TIMES THAT YOU
BRING MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THEY SHOULD NOT
OPPOSING ABOUT. ALL RIGHT HAVE
AN OFFER THE OP FOR. NOT TO S.
B. C. NINTHS. AND OKAY ARE FROM
COLLEAGUE TO THAT OF. AS SIX
NINE SO WILL GO TO. MOVING ON
TO MY COLLEAGUE MISTER LAWYERS
TO BE. ONE HEALTH FOR SO MATTER
PER- THIS IS A SUS CAL MISSED.
WERE PRESENT. THERE ARE NO
PRIME WITNESS HERE INSTEAD.
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE MIKE. AND
OF A ROOM TO FORTY. MONTEREY
PLEASE GO ON PHONE AND SUPPORT
OF S. B. C. FOUR TWO SENATOR
CALM WATER. LADIES AND IF YOU
TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF S. B. C.
FOUR TWO PRESS AND AT THE TIME.
ONCE AGAIN SUPPORT S. B. C.
FOUR TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND-
THANK NOTE ONE OF PART. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOW ON A- NOPE
WOULD ENOUGH. THERE'S NO IN
ROOM OPPOSE TO S. B. SIX TWO.
ANYONE IN ROOM TO FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TO FORTY. BATTERIES
OR ANYONE THE PHONE OPPOSED AS
PEACE. FOUR TWO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN YOU WISH TO ENOUGH
AND PRESS THE SIX TWO PRESS
ZERO. I WANT TO GET IF YOU
OPPOSE AT SIX TWO MAY PRESS ONE
AT THE- AND I SHOWED ONE AND
OPPOSITION. OUR HAVE A TAKEN
AND OPPOSITION COMMA OBJECTS A
COMMA ON THIS ONE THE OTHER ONE
OR BOTH. I KNOW YOU'RE GOOD.
ALL RIGHT. A S. SIX FORT WILL
TO. MOVING ON TO ASK SIX SEVEN
NINE. BY CENTER COMELEC LOSS IN
COUNTY AFFORDABLE. THE IS A
SYSTEM CANADA THE OFFER WAY PER-
NO PRIME WITNESSES INSIDE FROM
TO ROOM TWO- THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MY- IS THERE
ANYONE ROOM TO FORTY. THING
NINE WE WILL TO. WITNESSES
ANSWER ON THE PHONE. FOR SPC.
SEVEN NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORTERS S. B.
C. SEVEN NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT. WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
IN Q. ONE THIRTY SIGNATURE LINE
IS OPEN. A GOOD AFTER CHAIR AND-
WILL. ABOUT OF CALIFORNIA AND.
NEVER MIND OR TO JOHN JAVA
PRESS SIX NINETY MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NATIONAL
OFTEN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO A- OF S. B. C. SEVEN
NINE. OTHER NO FOR WHEN. THERE
NOBODY IN ROOM. FOR ANYONE IN
ROOM TO FORTY NO. MODERATOR
PLEASE GO UP ANY ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSE THIS PIECE. SEVEN
NINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN. OF STC
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AT
THIS TIME. WHAT ONE PERSON
QUEUE THAT COUNTER WITH AN
OPERATOR MOMENT PLEASE. THEY
HAVE TAKEN THE BACK YOU. WE
HAVE NO ONE ANOTHER. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GIVE IT A SECOND NOBODY
IN UP S. B. SIX NINE. AND WE
HAVE TAKEN THE OP CHRIS AND I.
UP. SIX SEVEN NINE. MISCON
HURDLE YEAH GO AHEAD YES I JUST
ONE TO SAY THAT IS ONE OF A TWO
SENATE BILL THAT I. BEEN S. SIX
NINE. AS INSPIRE BY FOR EIGHTY
WHICH PASSED BY THE- A CUP OF
YEARS WHICH WAS IN FOR IN MY-
DOWN. IT THOUSAND AND EIGHT
LEAVE BUILT CREATE. THE SAN
FRAN READ. S. FOURTEEN EIGHTIES
CREE THE BAY AREA HOUSING FIND
AGENCY- NEITHER WHICH OF THOSE
PUT ADDITIONAL PRESSURES ON THE
STATE COFFERS AND WERE BOTH
DESIGNED. TO PROVIDE HELP TO
FUND THE CONSTRUCTION OF
MODERATE AND LOW INCOME
HOUSING. AND THIS BILL IS DONE-
THE- IN THAT ESSENCE A GUEST
TAKING THE ESSENCE OF THOSE TWO
BILLS TO DO THAT FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY REGION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIX SEVEN NINE WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO SENATOR
ARCHULETA WHO HAS SB SIX FOUR
THREE ON FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION.
AND- PRIMARY WITNESSES WE WILL
TAKE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX FOUR THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S SO MANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN.
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FOUR THREE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO BE UP THE PART OF SB
POINT THREE YOU MAY ONE AT THE-
AT THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD BECOME PART OF SB SIX
POINT THREE MAY PRESS ONE AND-
AT THE TIME. I DON'T KNOW OF
THE PORTS CARE ALL RIGHT. BOB
THIS LET'S GO UP AS THERE'S NO
PRIMARY. THERE'S NOBODY THIS
ROOM IN OP. AS SIX THREE IS FOR
ANYWAY AND FROM TWENTY FOUR.
NOW MODERATORS ARE IN ON THE
PHONE OPPOSE SAYS SIX THREE BY
SEN ARCH ALETTA. LADIES
GENTLEMEN IF WISH TO SPEAK IT
UP AT THE OF SB SIX POINT THREE
YOU MADE. ONE ZERO AT THE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
ZERO SB POINT THREE. SPECIAL
WHAT ABOUT THE- OUR LET'S GO
BACK TO THE CAN THAT HERE
ASKING. SO WE WERE GO. TO OUR
POSITION WHICH IS SB SIX FOUR
THREE WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. BILLION SB
SIX SIX TWO BY SENATOR ARCHER
LETTER ON ENERGY TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR AND HYDROGEN. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE AT THE MICROPHONE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX TWO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN BECAUSE OF
S. B. C. SIX TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN AT THIS TIME. I WANT
TO GET A SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME SB SIX
SIX TWO. I SHOW NO ONE IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO
SUCH. LET'S MOVE TOP. THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSES SIX SIX TWO
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA. AND MADE
IT INTO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE OF AT SIX TWO YOU MAY
PRESS AT THE. WHAT BEGAN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK AT. YOU MAY PRESS
THE NEW FOR A SIX TWO. I SAW NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
HAVEN'T SUPPORT OPPOSITE OF S.
B. SIX SIX TWO BUT I OF. AND NO
COMMON FROM MIKE ABOUT. A SIX
SIX TWO. FOUR VERSUS. WE ARE
MOVING. SB SIX SEVEN ONE FIVE
THREE AND SO. ENTREE CLEAN
FREIGHT. EFFICIENT ASSESS. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE K. THE AUTHORS
WERE PRESENT. AND WE WILL.
COACH PUBLIC COMMENT SUPPORT
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM SUPPORT.
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SIR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK UP THE PART OF SB SIX
SEVEN ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. NATIONAL
HONOR SUPPORT THERE ARE RIGHT
NEXT MOVES OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
SEVEN ONE. THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SIX SEVEN ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU CAN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX SEVEN ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO FOR SB SIX SEVEN ONE. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SEVEN ONE
AND SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SIX SEVEN ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX FOUR CENTER GONZALEZ
ON SAFE DRINKING WATER AND
WATER. QUALITY THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION. THERE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- OH THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT. MONTEREY PLEASE COVER
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PART OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
DON'T THINK INITIAL SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO FOR SB.
SEVEN SEVEN SIX. I SAW NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE
WITH OUR OPPOSITION. SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX. THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITIES NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY AROUND
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEVEN IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
ONCE AGAIN ISSUE OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO FOR SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX. NATIONAL ONE
OPPOSING THE BILL I HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COAT YEAH MISS CONNOR GO AHEAD
HAVE POLICIES MISTER CHAIR I
JUST RECEIVED A TEXT THAT-
THERE ARE OVER TWENTY FIVE
PEOPLE THAT WERE NOT ABLE. THAT
ARE ON THE LINE ACTUALLY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVEN NINE BUT THEY SAID THE
LINE WASN'T WORKING SO I JUST
WANTED TO BRING IT TO YOUR
ATTENTION IN CASE THE MODERATOR.
FROM COULD FIND THEM. MONTEREY
DID YOU HEAR THAT. YEAH YES WE
ONLY HAVE SIX PEOPLE ON THE
CALL SO THERE WOULDN'T BE
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE TRYING TO
QUEUE UP ALL RIGHT SO LET'S
FINISH WITH SEVEN SEVEN SIX AND
THEN WE'LL LET THE FOLKS WHO
WANTED TO SPEAK ON THE OTHER
BILL DO THEIR THING. SO WE HAVE
TAKEN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX SENSING NO
QUESTIONS ON THAT WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AND
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP THE
FOLKS WHO WERE WORKING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF MISS CALM
WATERS BILL. THEIR THEIR- SIX
SEVEN HARPER WHICH OFTEN THAT
AFFECT. SB SIX SEVEN NINE. SIX
SEVEN NINE OKAY THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SIX.
PERFECT. EIGHT NINE. WHICH BILL
SB SIX HOLD ON ONE PERSON AT A
TIME SB SIX SEVEN NINE IS THE
BILL WE'RE GOING TO RE OPEN
PUBLIC COMMENT AND AGAIN OUR
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX. MY COUNTY BY
CASKETS SHIPPED. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO EIGHT ONE
SEVEN SO WE ARE GOING TO REOPEN
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX SEVEN NINE. OKAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SEVEN NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE MODERATOR CAN
LET ME KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
THAT IS. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT SB SIX SEVEN
NINE BUT I REMIND OUR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME FOR SB
SIX SEVEN NINE AND IF ANYONE
WHO HAS MISSED THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT THEY CAN
SEND THEIR WRITTEN COMMENTS
WHICH WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO PUT.
IN THE RECORD. SB SIX SEVEN
NINE GOING ONCE. GOING TWICE
MODERATE CHECK ONE MORE TIME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN ONCE AT
THE REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVEN NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I DON'T
KNOW WHEN IT'S SUPPORTER ALL
RIGHT WE ARE MOVING ON. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO TO SB SIX
EIGHTY NINE. FIVE SENATOR
HERTZBERG SB SIX EIGHTY NINE ON
RECORDS BLOCKCHAIN. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MAN THE
SENATOR HAS WAY PRESENTATION-
THERE IS NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. SIX EIGHTY NINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT
FOR SB SIX EIGHT NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER TO SELF
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX EIGHT NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THE BILL AT
THIS TIME. I SAW NO ONE IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
TO OPPOSITION OF SB SIX EIGHTY
NINE THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM. SEVEN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB SIX
EIGHTY NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THIS OPPOSITION TO SB
SIX EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN A SHORT
POSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME. I
DON'T KNOW WHEN IN OPPOSITION
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX EIGHTY
NINE ENCINO HANDS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIX EIGHT AND I WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. SB SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR BATES OUR VICE CHAIR.
THIS BILL IS ON HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE FOR SMALL EMPLOYER
GROUPS. SHE START SHE IS
GRACIOUSLY WAY PRESENTATION
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND
THIS BILL. WE WILL OPEN THE
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. DOLLARS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN EIGHTEEN ON HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN ONE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DON'T
THINK INITIAL SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN ONE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SAW NO ONE IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT LET'S
GOOD OPPOSITION S. B. ONE SEVEN
ONE EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY I KNOW
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
FIGHTERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB SEVEN ONE
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
ONE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN A
SHORT POSITION TO SB SEVEN ONE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ACTUALLY NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT HAVE A TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AND
SEEING NO HANDS OF MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVEN ONE EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE. OUR FINAL BILL AS THE
DAY IS SB SEVEN NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR CORTESE ON CALIFORNIA'S
SURPLUS LAND. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SUPPORT
OPPORTUNITY THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINETY ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN NINETY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I DON'T THINK INITIAL
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN NINE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I SAW NO ONE IN SUPPORT
FRESHMAN RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON OPPOSITION SB SEVEN NINETY
ONE THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINETY ONE. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IS OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN NINETY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO APPETITE. ONCE AGAIN
TO OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT HAVING OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION FOR SB SEVEN NINETY
ONE ON CALIFORNIA'S SURPLUS
LAND THING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVEN NINETY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE- THIS CONCLUDES ALL OF
THE BILLS ON OUR CALENDAR
THERE'S NOBODY THERE'S NO BILLS
ON CALL. THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING IN OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IT WAS AND IT
WAS ROBUST AND PASSIONATE. IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION AND WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS IS
ADJOURNED.